et monique d'amour entre monsieur
netanyahu et mme schierholz mais il n'y
avait pas main quand absence et
népalaises qui sont les dindons de la
farce en tout cas les grandit alors
donald trump qui pour la première fois
si j'ose dire évoque clairement une
solution réaliste deux états pour
résoudre ce conflit
ça vous semble complètement vous pas
crédible de la part du président
américain où il ya quand même une forme
de sincérité et d'efforts sur ce point
parce qu'on attendait en cette question
de de l'état de 2 et hr notamment à
l'union européenne
oui bon ça sert villa et a finalement on
est bien loin du plan de partage de la
palestine en 1947 puisque finalement
israël non seulement accroît son
territoire considérablement
donc il hérite finalement globalement on
peut comprendre que je ne connaissais
pas la teneur du document
d'ailleurs je pense que tu ne sais pas
si quelqu'un l'a connaît exactement dans
les détails territoriaux notamment où se
situerait l'état palestinien qu elle
soit l'état de l'état de stress telle
extension on sait par exemple que le
volant est reconnue déjà qui
n'appartient pas à israël et donc un tel
un territoire syrien
donc la direction il reconnu on sait que
donc le d'israël jérusalem est reconnue
comme la capitale éternelle de l'état
d'israël et qu'elle était une ville non
divisible ouverte mais non divisible
s'il y avait une capitale de l'état
palestinien
je ne sais pas si ça serait vraiment à
jérusalem est ou bien à l'est de
jérusalem
ce qui n'est pas tout à fait pareil
parce qu'on parle beaucoup d'habileté
plus lointaine banlieue c'est comme si
on était à melun finalement le capital
de la france
globalement je crois que ces portraits
séparés ensuite qu'à la diction
évidemment du tout les implantations
illégales israéliennes reconnus comme
territoires d'israël et puis ensuite
avec sur la vallée du jourdain qui est
une autre façon d'un ex intérimaires
n'appartient pas à israël
et puis au fond on en parle beaucoup de
l'incorporation de la zone c qui était
l'un des objets l'une des trois zones
prévues par les accords d'oslo et qui
n'a jamais été inquiet d'accord ils
n'ont jamais appliqué totalement et la
zone c c'était le à la zone de la
cisjordanie où israël détenait en fait
de garder l'essentiel des pouvoirs
à la fois sécuritaires militaires
politiques administratives etc
alors finalement israël bloque le ballon
si on reconnaissait y compris sur toutes
les implantations sur la donne c'est la
balle et de la zone de leur rôle dans la
vallée du jourdain était plus ou moins
souvent jordanienne actuellement et puis
jérusalem
et puis finalement le coupable le
collant pour israël
finalement si on a si on voit tout ça le
globalement il ne reste plus grand chose
à l'état brésilien
et c'est un coupet a songé bas laissant
alors les nippes haïtiens qui n'ont pas
été consultés qu'ils ont manifesté
d'ailleurs une production violente
je crois que ça présage des joueurs qui
ne sont pas des jours de peste un accord
de gastes un acte de guerre finalement
c'est un acte de piraterie en fait
diplomatique mais ça je pense que ça
peut pas passer
quelles peuvent être les conséquences
est ce qu'on peut craindre ces prochains
temps un embrasement comment vous voyez
les choses à l'avenir à ce que l'état
hébreu va y aller finalement entre
guillemets au forceps fort de ce plan
proposé par les états unis il ya ce qu
ils ont dans le plan des états unis
pensent comme vous connaissent que donc
c'est ce que je pense en général sur la
mais ce n'est pas le problème
sur le fond la marche des événements de
la région globalement je pense que là on
se demande si poulet aux événements dans
les pays arabes la déstabilisation que
les états de la région arabe musulman
plus généralement ça ne paie pas
finalement une partie d'un plan qu'ils
veulent non seulement une manipulation
de huit états de l'ue sur la région et
une déstabilisation du luth arabe et
musulman également disons préserver la
position d'israël comme une sangsue
stratégie numéro un dans la région ont
fait de la bri les intérêts sa sécurité
sa pérennité je pense que globalement
c'est ce qui c'est ce qui arrive
en réalité je note que monsieur dents
pendant la cérémonie qui a été fait à la
maison à la maison blanche entre une
assist auquel n'assistait que le seul
premier ministre israélien je pense que
les bienveillantes et net
on voyait que il y avait les trois
plaintes propres problèmes qui étaient
mentionnés dans l'accord et connexes qui
ont été mentionnés par monsieur trump
c'était d'abord de neutraliser les
grands comme se reproduisent et il faut
que la palestine est la région souhaite
délivrer du terrorisme ça personne ne
discute la question mais néanmoins
gothard quels sont les responsables
alors pour monsieur troc et pour les
israéliens il est clair que c'est le
grand et donc à les neutraliser l'iran
et donc le retrait d'une dune le retrait
des etats-unis du traité nucléaire
iranien était présenté comme étant une
au fond une partie de la transaction du
siècle par messieurs toile peut lui même
ensuite on demandait finalement une que
la palestine à venir soit exemple toute
erreur il se sent on veut bien croire et
on peut bien espérer est néanmoins ça
suppose finalement on voit bien qu'il
visait par là c'est le hamas me james
d'amis tous les mène au fond tous liés à
la nuit tous les mouvements de
résistance palestinienne qui serait
considérée comme il des pauvres parce
qu'on finirait comme étant des groupes
terroristes
puisque l'iran éliminé donc est donc
neutralisée globalement on voit bien
finalement que tout ce qui est arrivé
dans la
jean peut-être l'un des objectifs en
tout cas si dans l'objectif numéro 1
était de préserver l'aspect social et la
biosphère sa sérénité
alors la sécurité serbes pour israël
mais pas pour les autres états je crois
que les jours à venir
étant donné le rejet palestiniens et les
scènes vraiment je pense que là le
capital dame inscrits de haine qui a été
accumulée dans la région est vraiment
très très inquiétant et je crois que je
pars je pense qu'il faut pas demander à
monsieur tron de s'en rendre compte
mais par contre les diplomates et
d'autres pays dans la communauté
internationale il soit de la kz2 la
résistance qu'ils appartiennent à
l'europe ou pas l'europe
peu importe mais et y compris l'effet
d'une antelle devrait bien se préoccuper
de cette situation et de l'avenir de la
région
parce que c'est pas d'aujourd'hui
londres a dit que ça pourrait être une
avancée 1
ce plan proposé par donald trump quant à
moscou moscou vient de réagir et appelle
assez prosaïque mans israéliens et
palestiniens à négocier directement que
faut-il comprendre en gros ça ne regarde
pas les états unis qui doivent rester
hors de ce conflit
bah écoute et ils sont déjà en plein
conflit puisque c'est eux qui ont
présenté la solution qui n'est pas une
solution encore une fois puisqu'elle est
pas négocier culte est parti on sait que
mon amie on n'a jamais eu non n'ignore
pas que monsieur tom est un grand ami
d'israël et que dans la région il ne
voit que par israël c'est donc là c'est
la tradition américaine
alors les palestiniens sont lourds en
oublier les grandes victimes ont repris
cette affaire je ne reviendrai pas sur
les circonstances historiques l'entrée
en israël met donc finalement c'est
parfaitement injuste est une ignominie
du point de vue moral ça n'est pas une
lune un accord point de vue diplomatique
et c'est pas une solution du point de
vue politique puisque on a transformé le
problème israélo palestiniennes d'un
problème pas d'un problème politique
parce qu'il était au départ dans les
années 40 48 au monde arabe en israël on
attend ce moment une simple transaction
commerciale qui est dans le style de
monsieur train ne se trompe on n'imagine
pas que tous deux puissent pas s'acheter
ou se vendre y compris le destin d'un
peuple
il descend du pjak est dangereuse le
support qu'ils s'en fichent éperdument
évidemment personne n'a jamais douté
alors je crois pas que
finalement on peut prêcher le retour à
la négociation entre les palestiniens et
les israéliens
effectivement la solution à deux états
et était bien la solution qui était
reconnu comme étant lasse de réaliste
finalement par un tout est parti à un
moment donné et je dois désormais pour
qui les deux états il faut que les deux
états est une base sur un territoire qui
est quand même extrêmement limitée et la
palestine historique
or finalement on a neutralisé
globalement tous les états qui pourrait
soutenir la cause palestinienne
notamment la syrie le golan syrien
d'ailleurs est considérée comme étant
une partie fine maintenant par une
sereine lui même et par l'amérique
la ligue de la ville de jérusalem est
une ville totalement israélienne parce
que je crois que la capitanat l'est
d'israël comme ceux dont on parlait
beaucoup
disons en dix ans des 50 milliards de
financement de projets de développement
sur les territoires qui seraient
dévolues à l'état palestinien
oui je crois j'ai entendu ce mot là
alors effectivement c'est tous les pays
toutes les parties que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure la zone cesser les implantations
israéliennes
c'est jérusalem c'est la vallée du
jourdain ils seraient tous les chats
prêts au fonds à une regard de la
jordanie et qui seraient considérés
comme faisant partie de l'année une
partie du sahel et tout ça donc c'est
sûr des cadeaux donnés par monsieur tron
pas israël mais des cadeaux qui sont
très près de très bon marché parce que
son tour des cadeaux avec des données
des choses et des territoires qui lui
appartiennent pas alors ça c'est merci
beaucoup d'avoir site avec nous de nous
avoir apporté votre point de vue après
la présentation de ce plan de donald
trump un plan de paix présenté donc
aujourd'hui à washington sur lequel nous
reviendrons bien évidemment longuement
dans notre édition de 21h notamment nous
en débattrons à 21h30 en direct avec nos
invités merci à vous journée
journée de manifestations pour les
pompiers qui annonce mettre fin ce soir
à leur mobilisation après les annonces
de christophe castaner ils ont notamment
obtenu une revalorisation salariale à
maintien de leur système de retraite et
une augmentation de leurs primes de feu
de 6%
le ministre de l'intérieur a salué la
décision des syndicats de mettre fin à
la grève des annonces du ministère de
l'intérieur après une manifestation
marquée par de nombreux cet après midi
dans la capitale plusieurs milliers de
pompiers ont manifesté pour dénoncer le
monde moyen exigé le maintien de leur
système de retraite trois
interpellations ont été annoncés retour
en images sur les fortes tensions lors
de cette journée
av
m
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
les
g
or les manifestations violences en marge
de ces manifestations nous avons reçu
christophe pépin porte-parole de france
police pour en parler écouter soleil je
sais qu'il ya eu un blessé léger du côté
des pompiers
mais je vous le dire que ma parité
syndicale france police policiers en
colère nous sommes avec les peaux les
pompiers qui ont des doléances qui nous
semble pour nous légitime à la sarre du
fait que les violences nous les avons
toujours dénoncé aujourd'hui les
instructions de la préfecture de police
sont très claires il faut vraiment qu'il
n'y est vraiment pas mal de possibilité
d'avoir deux casses ou quoi que ce soit
c'est la raison pour laquelle cette
manifestation est temps qu'à l'abri
d'une manière très serrée des
dispositifs policiers justement
aujourd'hui comment quel est le
dispositif policier justement juger des
gendarmes mobiles gd des compagnies
républicaines de sécurité et aussi des
dispositifs de la préfecture de police
qui sont tout au long chemin vous des
deux chiffres comme ça parce que en fait
c'était volutes ifs en fait on a des
gens qui sont tout le long de la
manifestation
là on va arriver sur la fin de cortège
sur le fait qu'ils veuillent puis
laiteries sur le périphérique
je pense que c'est inconcevable parce
que il expose peut même leur vie et ils
s'exposent à des complications assez
conséquente
concernant leurs doléances pour nous
elles sont louables mais faut pas
oublier une chose pour vos
téléspectateurs c'est que en fait les
pompiers travaillent sous instruction du
ministère de l'intérieur
comme la police nous on n'est pas du
tout opposée aux pompiers au contraire
on apprécie beaucoup de travailler main
dans la main
et là aujourd'hui la préfecture de
police ou des instructions qui sont très
clairs et qu'ils sont justement de ne
pas de ne pas laisser à la pour trouver
un paquet qui les actions que ce soit
sur les réseaux sociaux les violences
cet après midi ont fait réagir de
nombreuses personnalités politiques
les pompiers dans la rue les forces de
l'ordre n'hésitent pas à leur taper
dessus
gaz lacrymogène à gogo îlots osé faire
grève et ne pas respecter l'itinéraire
ils dénoncent le manque d'effectifs et
de reconnaissance et demandent des
garanties pour leur retraite guerre
fratricide
selon le ministre lunn aise la police
aurait porté à bout de bras la
république
dans la répression des manifestations
retraite la macro ni on est là la police
matraquer pompiers frapper ainsi ce qui
sauve nos vies est indigne le régime
autoritaire macro nist défigure la
république crs posez vos casques et
matraques rebellez vous vous ne pouvez
être fiers d'appliquer ses ordres
absurdes à nouveau des images
terrifiantes de pompiers en colère
matraquer les français ont eu macron et
le cas au maquereau et le chaos
ces images sont désespérantes emmanuel
macron qui a réussi à jeter nos
policiers contre nos pompiers devraient
réfléchir à l'immense responsabilité qui
est la sienne dans la profonde des
unions de notre pays
les policiers tabassent les pompiers
institutions contre institutions la
macro nice et la division et le chaos
lorsqu'un pays voit descendre dans ses
rues pompiers hospitaliers enseignants
étudiants chercheurs avocats
l'orchestré de l'opéra de paris et tant
d'autres c'est bien que sa société
craque de toutes parts emmanuel macron
doit savoir
on n'est pas prêt de lâcher la faire
écouter ses paroles de pompiers
recueillies lors de la manifestation
dont vous voyez que là on a un gros coup
pour le repos de sécurité ou en fin de
compte c'est vous regardez on devra
travailler 12 heures par la loi
européenne
mais on applique les lois en fait en
fonctionnement comme ça les arrange et
ses problèmes en fait d'ailleurs que
nous on n'est pas reconnu comme étant à
risque au niveau salaire on est des fois
puis moins cher qu'un carrie peur que
mes joueurs et c'est ça qui on n'a rien
contre eux au contraire ils le méritent
leur salaire mais nous on est prêt à
risquer notre vie pour tout le monde
pour tout le monde même pour les gens
qui nous agressent quand on se fait
agresser dans la rue quand on se fait
agresser sur intervention
si ces gens là étaient en repli dans un
peu on seraient même prêts à donner leur
vie pour pourquoi 28% pour qu'elles
soient justement égal à la police
on estime qu'une autre métier aussi
risqué que les policiers malheureusement
on le voit tous les ans avec des
collègues décédés
nous estimons aussi que notre métier est
super à adu
plus de risques liés aux cancers
notamment aux fumées au rythme de
travail de 24 heures qui usent santé non
sapeurs pompiers aujourd'hui ne pas
partir à 50 normalement rentrer et c'est
pas possible on a un métier qui est
pénible qui est difficile quand la nuit
ont subi tradition voilà le métier se
complique
la france va mal
aujourd'hui et on le voit dans plein de
profession mais les tensions n'ont pas à
être justifiée mais les pompiers ont le
sentiment de ne pas avoir été entendus
selon aurélien guéant secrétaire
départemental du syndicat sud au sdis du
département du pas-de-calais
c'est difficile à dire je trouve ça ne
leur fait mais ce qu'il faut comprendre
c'est quand même pas mal de pompiers qui
sont un peu à bout après quand même
plusieurs mois de grève il ya ce que ça
fait de vouloir veiller rien jusqu'à
derrien justifiée parce que encore une
fois on a eu une manifestation le 14 le
15 octobre dernier s'est passé
exactement de la même manière ou place
nation on a été menacé et on pouvait pas
rejoindre nos bus où on s'est fait gazer
cherche pas d'excusé ou quoi que ce soit
il y en a qui sont plus gênés avec
d'autres certainement toujours est il
que depuis quand même le mois de juin
l'année dernière on sent on est en grève
et que les réponses à cette grève du de
la part du gouvernement on parle de nous
violence physique sauf que il ya de la
violence psychologique qui fait par le
gouvernement depuis plusieurs mois voire
plusieurs années sur les pompiers si on
a des avancées sur nos revendications le
mouvement s'arrêtera et tout le monde
repartira bon enfant je veux dire il
nous on n'est pas content d'être là je
veux dire moi je préfère battre dans ma
caserne dans ma maison avec ma famille
plutôt que de venir manifester ainsi
tout allait bien un retour aux
prud'hommes pour les salariés de
goodyear ils contestent le motif
économique de leur licenciement en 2014
la première audience en 2018 n'ayant pas
permis de trancher les nouvelles c'est
ouverte à 9h à mégacité à amiens le
point avec katia pique nique
c'est le second procès aux prud'hommes
des anciens employés de goodyear
aujourd'hui il souhaite évidemment
porter une demande d'indemnisation mais
également que leur travail et leur
dévouement pour leur ancienne société
soit reconnue c'est bien sûr un procès
historique aujourd'hui puisque pas moins
de huit cent trente deux anciens
salariés poursuivent leur ancien
employeur goodyear devant les tribunaux
alors évidemment un tribunal était trop
petit pour les accueillir il a fallu
délocaliser le procès est ici à mégacité
c'est un complexe de congrès à amiens et
dès 7h30 du matin plus de 600 personnes
sont venues assister à ce procès hors
norme un petit rappel des faits en 2014
l'usiné goodyear d'amiens nord a fermé
1134 emplois y ont été licenciés et l'
usine a fini par être rasées aujourd'hui
c'était l'émotion pour les anciens
salariés
je vous propose de les écouter on espère
vraiment qu'il soit prouvé encore une
fois parce que ces palabres et avant que
c'est un licenciement abusif et on
attend vraiment des réponses est con
goodyear enfin reconnaissent que j'ai
que ces licenciements abusifs tout le
monde malheureusement dans des
circonstances comme ça tout le monde se
revoient et ça c'est vraiment important
pour nous ça nous permet justement ma de
de prendre un peu des nouvelles de types
différents collègues
malheureusement il ya des collègues
qu'il n'y en ait un qui viendront pu
parce que voilà ils sont et sur des cds
mais on pense à eux et on se bat aussi
pour eux j'espère qu'on a tous les
goodyear c'est que reconnaissent déjà le
travail effectué on a réalisé dans cette
usine
parce qu'il fallait de courageux pour
travailler un coup dur surtout fallait
être courageux pour produire jusqu'à 24
mille peu de jours et je peux vous dire
qu'il ya pas beaucoup d'usinés en europe
à l'époque il était capable de faire ce
cette production et nous à goodyear
amiens nord
on l'a réussi en touche et des des
produits nocifs
à l'époque on nous a pas dit que c'était
nocifs et je pense à tous ces gens là
qui sont tombés malades
pour certains qui est pour certains qui
en sont noirs et aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
de là où j'espère que il j'espère que
l'on va gagner pour eux l'avocat des
anciens de goodyear maître fiodor rilov
est un grand nom du barreau est
également un habitué des combats contre
les multinationales il a expliqué ce
matin lors d'une plaidoirie fleuve de
quatre heures que la société l'année
2014 année de la fermeture avait un
profit record 2,5 milliards de bénéfices
et donc l'argument économique pour
licencier les anciens salariés ne tenait
pas je vous propose de l'écouter
ainsi que d'écouter mickaël wamen qui
est le porte parole des anciens salariés
de goodyear de démonstration faite au
conseil des prud'hommes
d'abord les profits pharaonique réalisé
par goodyear au moment même où ils
licenciait les 1200 salariés de l'usiné
d'amiens nord sont non seulement une
situation scandaleuse mais surtout une
situation illégale on ne peut pas
licencier des milliers de personnes
lorsqu'on fait en même temps
simultanément des bénéfices aussi énorme
et je pense que ça c'est à la portée
de tout un chacun de comprendre qu'il
faut que le groupe qui décide ainsi de
fermer son usine pour faire encore
davantage de profits soient lourdement
sanctionnés sans exemple en quelque
sorte dissuasif va démontrer avec des
preuves pas uniquement avec des paroles
mais des preuves concrètes que cette
multinationale qui a fermé ses cuisines
est en réalité a fait tout et n'importe
quoi violé tous les règles de droit
élémentaires et donc on va voir ce que
va dire l'apathie adverse après midi
mais pendant près de quatre heures
fiodor a fait une démonstration qui est
limpide voilà il ya même pas l'ombre
d'un doute sur les faits qui sont avérés
c'est à dire que goode eurent à fermer
l'usiné alors qu'il était en santé
économique
excellent d'ailleurs c'était sa
meilleure année une année record
aussi bien en termes de résultat net
après impôt qu en termes de dividendes
donc une fois encore on est dans une
situation où la variable d'ajustement
pour faire quoi verser plus de
dividendes aux actionnaires
c'est la masse salariale et donc c'est
les séries qui ont craqué après la pause
c'est l'avocat de goodyear qui a repris
la parole et qui a expliqué que l' usine
d'amiens nord n'avait pas assez de
rentabilité à l'époque et que toutes les
offres que ce soit en terme de
restructuration ou les offres de
propositions de départs ont été toutes
refusées par qui par la cgt et les
salariés et que donc il s'agissait d'
obstruction cela a fait beaucoup réagir
dans la salle en tout cas aujourd'hui à
amiens il y a un espoir d'enfants
tourner la page goodyear après toutes
ces années pour d'anciens salariés qui
entre temps sont devenus une véritable
famille on est dans quelques instants
rester avec nous nous parlerons de la
mise au point de la cour de cassation
après les propos d' emmanuel macron sur
les faire ça à nimy puis direction
l'hémicycle en proie à la fronde de
certains parlementaires qui dénoncent la
façon expéditive dont est traité le
texte sur la réforme des retraites
non
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
ma passion c'est les chiens nordiques
que j'irai donc le chien de race husky
de sibérie qu'est ce qu'ils représentent
pour vous ces chiens un meilleur
présente ce plein de choses parce que
c'est de l'amour de l'amour au quotidien
je chassais pas une motoneige c'est pas
une machine c'est pour vous faire
plaisir bien souvent du coup chaque
chien à son caractère il ya certaines de
mes chiennes on expliquer leur règne par
le regard on arrive à se comprendre
cette année on a fait un parcours à
l'envers arrivé à un moment depuis des
années enfin à gauche
cette année elle nous a fait prendre la
piste par la droite comment alors
la chienne de tête à s'est retourné et
m'a dit tu es sur ton coup parce que
c'est pas par la fois les ce et d'autres
côtes et bienvenue sur rt france merci
nous rejoindre 20h30 en direct les faits
rallye me revient sur le devant des
scènes accompagné de la colère des plus
hauts magistrats contre emmanuel macron
jeudi dernier le président de la
république avait commenté la décision de
la cour d'appel de paris de déclarer
irresponsable pénalement l'homme accusé
du meurtre de la sexagénaire juive
hier la cour de cassation lui a répondu
les détails avec leila sarah la
polémique ne retombe pas même s'il admet
que commenter une décision de justice
n'est pas sa fonction lors de son
déplacement en israël jeudi dernier
emmanuel macron s'est permis d'évoquer
le meurtre de sarah halimi
même si à la fin le juge devait décider
que la responsabilité pénale n'est pas
là le besoin de procès lui est là le
besoin que toutes les voix s'expriment
dé et que l'on comprenne ce qui s'est
passé pour que ce que tout un procès
comporte de réparation parce qu'il est
lui même puisse se tenir
emmanuel macron a peut-être manqué une
occasion de se taire
il a fallu seulement trois jours au
président de la république pour se faire
recadrer ce lundi la cour de cassation
plus haute juridiction de l'ordre
judiciaire en france lui a répondu dans
un message
la première présidente de la cour de
cassation et le procureur général près
cette cour rappelle que l'indépendance
de la justice dont le président de la
république est le garant est une
condition essentielle du fonctionnement
de la démocratie
les magistrats de la cour de cassation
doivent pouvoir examiner en toute
sérénité et en toute indépendance les
pourvois dont ils sont saisis
une mise au point rarissime co billy
traoré mise en examen pour le meurtre de
la sexagénaire juive en avril 2017 ne
pourra pas être jugé aux assises malgré
la colère des parties civiles et de
certains représentants de la communauté
juive
la chambre de l'instruction a conclu à
l'abolition de son discernement au
moment des faits n'en déplaise au
président de la république et pour en
parler nous sommes en direct avec
béatrice brugère secrétaire général
adjoint du syndicat national des
magistrats est faux bond soir béatrice
brugère merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france vous comprenez 7
ce recadrage de la cour de cassation
envers le président de la république je
sais pas si on peut parler de recadrage
que l'on peut dire d'abord que c'est une
communication de la cour de cassation
qui est quand même à sare
donc il faut la prend aussi comme tel
c'est à dire qu'elle est importante elle
est courte vue elle est lapidaire et
qu'est ce qu'elle dit
dit elle rappelle tout simplement nos
institutions dans nos institutions pour
la france en tout cas en ce qui concerne
la france le président de la république
est garant de l'indépendance de la
justice et c'est extrêmement important
c'est à dire que en fait comme les
garants de cette indépendance
il ne peut prendre position surtout sur
une affaire en cours
c'est ça le problème c'était l'affairé
la en cours elle n'est pas du tout
terminé il ne peut prendre position pour
donner son opinion
d'autant plus que là et ça c'est quand
même un deuxième fait il se trouve à
l'étranger
donc on a rarement on en parlera
exactement mobilier dont on a rarement
l'habitude de voir un président de la
république parle et d'affaires
intérieures j'allais dire à l'étranger
qui plus est est une affaire qui est
quand même extrêmement sensible en cette
affaire elle a déjà donné lieu à
beaucoup de commentaires donc voilà donc
le rappel de la cour de cassation est
déjà un rappel institutionnels et ça ça
me sens déjà très important de le
rappeler pour vous il ya une forme de
tentative d'ingérence
on peut interpréter cela comme ça je
viens de réécouter la séquence avec vous
le message est très clair c'est à dire
que ce que dit le président de
république ne veut pas être mais
interprété pas du tout au contraire et
je pense qu'il est assez clair de quoi
il est question aujourd'hui il est
question de savoir si oui ou non la cour
de cassation qui fait l'objet en fait un
pourvoi en bourse un peu technique va
décider de renvoyer ou pas donc très
joli
pardon devant une cour d'assises il ya
un premier arrêt qui a été rendu par la
chambre d'instruction qui a dit que pour
l'instant en l'état vu son état
psychiatrique
on ne pouvait pas le renvoyer devant une
cour d'assises ce que dit le président
de la république c'est qu'il ya un
besoin de procès je crois que le message
est clair quand on sait qu'aujourd'hui
c'est la question qui est à l'étude
alors c'est vrai que cette affaire comme
vous l'avez déjà fait couler beaucoup
d'encre elle a créé la polémique c'est
vrai que le 19 décembre dernier on le
rappelle la chambre d'instruction de la
cour d'appel a rendu un arrêt très
discutée dans cette affaire dite aussi
ultra sensible charges suffisantes
maltais ans sauf erreur de ma part
caractère antisémite retenue mais
l'assassin pénalement irresponsable on
évoquait l'emprise du cannabis
c'est vrai que c'est un contexte
difficile dans avec une augmentation des
actes antisémites en france a besoin de
de justice
est ce qu'on peut comprendre que le
président tente effectivement de donner
un petit peu
voilà son avis sur la question où c'est
totalement inacceptable selon vous si
vous voulez en fait la question elle se
pose pas de cette manière la question
elle se pose sur à mon avis trois
aspects premier aspect c'est un problème
politique
quand on est à l'extérieur on ne parle
pas des affaires intérieures
ça c'est un premier problème deuxième
problème si sûr sur un plan
institutionnel notre constitution
demande au président de la république de
garantir l'indépendance une prise de
parole sur un dossier en cours est une
prise de parole qui ne peut pas être
neutre puisque le dossier n'est pas
terminée donc obligatoirement ça peut
s'apprécier comme une pression politique
c'est une femme une forme de
contamination politique d'un dossier
judiciaire et troisièmement
juridiquement parlant ça pose un
troisième place c'est que ça donne de la
confusion dans le débat public c'est à
dire que vous avez un dossier qui est
déjà extrêmement sensible parce qu en
fait on est sur un dossier en y fait
horrible dans un contexte de montée
d'actes antisémites est donc
évidemment que ce dossier va crispé et
va si vous voulez dans l'opinion
publique
obligatoirement aussi donner un aspect
pour ou contre
donc encore plus dans ce genre de
dossier il ne faut pas prendre de parole
parce que la décision n'est pas
définitive
donc oui ça pose un vrai problème et
c'est la raison pour laquelle la cour de
cassation a fait ce rappel à l'ordre est
alors la porte parole du gouvernement si
bête and dye a tenté de rétropédaler en
tout cas de d'assurer qu'il y avait eu
une interprétation des propos du
président sur l' affaire halimi et qu'on
ne fait pas dans ce gouvernement de
pression sur qui que ce soit on
partageait on va vous adhérez en tout
cas cette défense non je crois que les
propos du président sont très claires et
dire qu'il ya une mésinterprétation ce
serait dire que le président est confus
je ne crois pas qu'on puisse dire ça
après on comprend le contact dans lequel
il s'exprime ce contexte n'est pas
anodin il n'est pas neutre il est en
israël on sait que quand même il ya une
très grande sensibilité de la communauté
juive sur ce dossier on comprend
pourquoi ce contexte n'est pas neutre on
peut pas parler de mes interprétations
non mais par contre c'est un vrai
problème c'est à dire que il ya de plus
en plus d'irruption du politique dans
les affaires judiciaires en france et il
est tout à fait normal et sain qu'on
rappelle les institutions je rappelle
aussi que
sur le plan donc de la constitution il
est garant de l'indépendance mais que la
seule personne dans notre code qui peut
s'exprimer parce que il ya quand même
des personnes qui peuvent s'exprimer
justement pour faire de la pédagogie sur
certains dossiers qui sont comme ça très
sensible c'est le procureur de la
république
donc nous avons quand même des personnes
qui peuvent s'exprimer sur des dossiers
en cours et notre code de procédure
pénal dit très clairement que c'est le
procureur de la république qui peut le
faire est-ce que selon vous il y a des
précédents où c'est sous l'hère macron
les choses semblent s'envenimer on
connaît les relations difficiles qui
avaient notamment nicolas sarkozy avec
une partie de la magistrature
est ce que c'est un fait surprenant pour
un président de la république alors il
ya déjà bien sûr il ya des précédents on
va pas dire que c'est un fait historique
ce qui est quand même assez nouveau
c'est que ça se fasse à l'étranger
ça c'est quand même assez particulier
nous on a déjà eu des irruptions du
politique sur des affaires judiciaires
et c'est d'ailleurs bien le problème de
notre système
en france c'est de reclassifier qui fait
quoi qui a le droit de faire quoi et
c'est un problème d'institutions je
rappelle d'ailleurs à ce propos qui a
une commission d' enquête qui vient de
s'ouvrir la demande d'ailleurs de la
france insoumise sur la question de
l'indépendance de la justice
donc on voit bien que cette thématique
elle est posée sur la table en france
particulièrement en france et que il
faut clarifier absolument nos
institutions sur ce point là comment le
vivent les magistrats ce type de
pressions quel est l'impact sur sur un
professionnel de la magistrature alors
moi je prendrais pas de pression parce
que pour parler de pression il faut
pouvoir être impressionné et je ne sais
pas si les magistrats de la cour de
cassation sont impressionnés par ce qui
a été dit je pense que c'est plutôt un
rappel général
si vous voulez de ce qui peut se faire
et de ce qui ne peut pas se faire et
d'ailleurs la communication de la cour
de cassation
c'est ce qu'elle dit et a dit laissez
nous travailler de manière sereinement
je pense que les magistrats et je
l'espère sont tout à fait aptes à
résister à cette pression mais
c'est vrai que c'était c'est important
de le rappeler et on ne devrait pas
avoir à le rappeler emmanuel macron qui
rappelle que la question de
l'antisémitisme pour lui et celle de la
république
on l'a rappelé il ya un contexte très
émotif très sensible autour de ces
questions vous le dites et magistrats ne
cède pas aux pressions mais tout de même
ils lisent la presse il écoute les
informations comme en partie percevoir
cette émotion dans un pays
ils n'en sont pas moins citoyens on vous
dit on lit la presse on vit dans notre
société on le voit aussi mais encore une
fois à la question de l'antisémitisme
qui est un vrai problème puisque je le
rappelle on a une croissance d actes
antisémites et pas et pas qu'eux et pas
que d'ailleurs donc c'est un vrai sujet
c'est d'abord un sujet politique
avant d'être un sujet judiciaire c'est à
dire qu'il ya déjà des leviers
politiques pour lutter contre
l'antisémitisme
j'allais dire que nous quand on arrive
c'est presque trop tard c'est que les
actes ont déjà eu lieu donc nous on est
là pour les sanctionner
mais du côté du politique plein de
choses à faire et le président de la
république a tout à fait raison de s'en
emparer simplement lui misé qui doit
faire c'est du politique
merci en tout cas à vatry ce brugère
secrétaire générale adjointe du syndicat
national des magistrats est fou d'avoir
apporté votre opinion en direct sur rt
france percyais même si la fronde
parlementaire se poursuit aujourd'hui
les députés aient l'air de monde
un nouveau projet de loi sur la réforme
des retraites il dénonce le site la
précipitation et l'amateurisme de
l'exécutif écoute et damien abad
président du groupe l'est républicain à
l'assemblée nationale s'est dit
aujourd'hui ne pouvons accepter de
devoir examiner un projet de loi sur les
retraites sans que nous ne sachions rien
de son financement
nous n'avons aucune idée de l'incidence
financière de cette réforme alors même
que les retraites représente plus de 320
milliards d'euros par an 14 % de la
richesse nationale et 25% des impôts des
français ne pouvons pas non plus
accepter l'amateurisme et
l'improvisation permanente dont fait
preuve ce gouffre
man sur un sujet aussi essentiel qui va
déterminer l'avenir de millions de
français
cette fonte des républicains s'ajoute la
lettre de 75 députés majoritairement de
gauche cette fois au président de
l'assemblée nationale objectif dénoncer
les conditions d'examen du texte de loi
sur la réforme des retraites il regrette
le délai d'étude du projet quatre jours
trop court selon eux ils contestent
également le temps de parole donnée à
l'opposition et demandent à richard
ferrand le jeu s'y défendre l'honneur du
palais beau bourg
ces conditions de travail sont
inadmissibles et ne peuvent que nous
inspirer de la honte vis-à-vis de celles
et de ceux qui nous ont confié l'honneur
exigeant de les représenter
le choix d'un examen de ce texte qui
divise le pays en procédure accélérée
relève de la démocratie expéditive
alors que nous croyons à la nécessité
d'un débat parlementaire
nous vous demandons solennellement de
défendre cet honneur celui de
l'assemblée dont vous êtes le président
et qui ne saurait être dissoute dans les
exigences de l'exécutif et pour en
parler nous sommes avec stéphane rozès
président de cap conseil analyse et
perspective bonsoir c'est ma grossesse
merci d'être avec nous on connaissait
évidemment la grande fronde sociale les
grèves les mêmes mobilisation
mobilisation sur le terrain et puis ça y
est la fronde maintenant parlementaire
hier la gauche aujourd'hui la droite est
ce que l'étau se resserre clairement sur
l'exécutif sur ce projet de réforme des
retraites
alors il ya un mécontentement de la
gauche et de la droite c'est assez
attendu au fond après
de longues semaines de mouvement social
sur les retraites le fait que toujours
deux français sur trois soient opposés à
la réforme
et puis il y a des signes de
fragilisation à l'intérieur même du
groupe parlementaire et donc il ya un
sentiment sur la réforme en général
qu'elle a mal été préparé après tout ce
temps quand même où il ya eu des
concertations autour de jean paul
delevoye est que dans la toute dernière
ligne droite
le parlement n'est ce pas et demander à
rapidement voté la loi de façon très
précipitée de santi n'y aura eu ni
réellement une séquence de dialogue
social y aura eu des concertations mais
pas de dialogue et puis au plan du
parlement le sentiment qu'ils ne ratent
pas eu non plus enfin qu'il n'ya pas les
conditions pour à 1
un débat parlementaire riche et avec le
temps nécessaire mais justement ça c'est
la nouveauté ce qui j'ose dire c'est un
argument peut-être qui fait sens avant
on était dans l'opposition l'essayer
d'annoncé et d'avancer ses arguments
contre cette réforme et maintenant on y
voit là on nous impose ça on a quatre
jours
est-ce que c'est justement l'argument
qui peut faire mouche et conduire au
retrait avec le conseil d'état rappelle
qu'ils sont aimés les hier non je ne
crois pas que les rapports de force au
sein du parlement le permettent mais au
fond il ya pour sans doute le président
et le gouvernement
actant au fond une forme d'impopularité
l'idée qu' il représenterait au moins à
la fois l'or est à la fois le sentiment
que mais elles font des choses
il réforme le pays comme si c'était pour
les français une finalité en soi en or
pour les français la réforme est un
moyen au service d'une vision est là
l'exécutif semble être mû par l'idée de
il faut avancer et c'est au pays de
s'adapter c'est aux forces politiques de
s'adapter c'est aux partenaires sociaux
de s'adapter comme si le mouvement était
en soi pour le l'exécutif une finalité
est ce que c'est la réforme qui va qui
risque de faire perdre
l'exécutif en tout cas la majorité aux
municipales on voit un sondage c'est peu
encourageants pour emmanuel macron paru
chez oddo que ça trois français sur 10
qui veulent sanctionner le président de
la république aux prochaines municipales
oui alors il faut il faut faire
attention à ce type de sondage c'est de
l'ancien directeur ainsi du sondage qui
vont passer en fait ces municipales
d'ailleurs ça a été le problème
d'incompréhension du président mac on le
verra peut-être si on parle des
principales villes où il ya des
dissensions
ces municipales plus qu'aucune autre les
motivations de vote seront pas du tout
des motivations nationales ou sur des
étiquettes mais au contraire sur des
personnes sûreté prochai donc bien sûr
il ya des questions des formulations des
questions et des priorisations ou pas
des questions si le climat national
devait peser ce sera un climat national
anti gouvernement mais cette variable ne
va pas être la variable principal
si emmanuel macron et la république en
marche ont des problèmes aux municipales
c'est à mon avis sans doute beaucoup
plus qu'ils n'ont pas soit trouver des
bons candidats soit parce qu'ils n'ont
pas d'ancrage local suffisamment
importante pour que leur candidat puisse
mener dans de bonnes conditions
une campagne basée sur des enjeux locaux
est-ce que la république en marche est
en train de déchanter cet enthousiasme
qu'on a connu à la présidentielle on
voit l'hémorragie au sein de de ce parti
vient des changements réels oublier
absolument vous avez tout à fait raison
il ya maintenant us environ 12 députés
qui ont quitté la république en marche
on ne sait pas s'ils vont rester
apparentés s'ils vont faire quelque
chose d'autre mais au fond quand le
maquereau nice m'arrive c'est une sorte
de licorne politique une sorte d'objet
nos d'identifier et quand le lien entre
le président qui est arrivé sur une
question un peu néo bonapartiste de
rapport direct avec le pays se délite
alors c'est tout ce qu'il y a entre les
deux dans la ma chronique qui est du
coup absolument bousculé alors on le
voit dans les défections de députés qui
quitte un rythme maintenant plus
important la république en marche et on
le voit dans le fait que le tiers des
villes de 50 des 50 premières villes il
ya des dissidents salle on pense
évidemment par la dissidence paris mais
il ya paris lyon marseille toulouse et
nice par exemple dans les villes de plus
important tout au fond le candidat
retenu même si c'est un maire sortant
d'ailleurs de droite en général ça ne
passe pas et donc il ya des velléités de
personnes qui étaient la république en
marche de présenter leur propre liste
comment justement vous expliquer ces
dissidents avaient commencé à nous
donner une explication mais prenons le
cas de paris effectivement c'est
emblématique il n'y a pas d'autorité de
légitimité benjamin griveaux a été a été
choisi et finalement ne respecte pas ce
choix
alors il ya on l'a dit tout à l'heure le
fait que le président dans son lien ou
pays a perdu beaucoup de la confiance
dont il a bénéficié pendant un an il
pouvait réformer parce qu'il avait une
vision passé semble être mû par ce
qu'était le peuple français est alors
donc on considérer que ces réformes
pourraient être injuste socialement
le pays qu'on sentait parce qu'il
semblait vouloir restaurer la
souveraineté de la nation
à partir du moment où angela merkel
l'empêchent d'avoir ce deuxième étape de
construction de maquereaux nisme il
semble reprendre la politique de ses
prédécesseurs et donc du coup avec les
gilets jaunes et la réforme des
retraites du coup la question de la
justice sociale
devient un nouveau prééminente alors
qu'est-ce qui se passe
il se passe que d'habitude en tout cas
pour les grandes villes le président de
la république
antérieurement il suivait tous les
dossiers prenons paris machin grévaux a
une mauvaise image
cédric villani avait la meilleure image
auprès des parisiens le score de
benjamin griveaux tient essentiellement
à ce que on sait que le président est
derrière benjamin griveaux mais au
moment de la décision sans doute que les
arbitrages qui ont été choisis n'ont pas
été les bons donc on sentait un
président de la république qu'il voulait
pas trop rentrer dans les détails de ces
questions de candidature aux municipales
parce qu'on sait que ça n'intéresse pas
énormément le président mais n'était pas
dans une situation telle avec dans son
rapport aux pays qui pouvait laisser
sous traiter ça donc
en un mot à paris des choses se sont
très mal passé parce que elles n'ont pas
été du point de vue de l'image des
candidats auprès des parisiens est le
fait de savoir qui pouvait porter un
projet alternatif à l'image mauvaise
d'ailleurs de la maire sortante anne
hidalgo alors dans le même temps il ya
quand même des chiffres encourageants la
baisse du chômage la france attractive
en europe ça veut dire que les français
ne regarde même plus ça ne voit plus ses
bonnes
nouvelle vous avez tout à fait raison de
mettre en avant les améliorations à
gauche active dans le pays
mais au fond ça ramène à des questions
beaucoup plus profond de d'où vient la
dépression française alors moi ça fait
des années que je dis qu selon moi cette
dépression n'a pas des raisons
essentiellement économiques et sociales
la france même si son modèle social est
dégradée est dans une situation très
avantageuses
et d'ailleurs beaucoup de nos amis
européens en vie la situation française
il vaut mieux être un salarié français
qu'un salarié allemand a face à nous
répondrons pas ajustements alors
justement alors tout bien celle des
pressions et bien justement n'ont pas de
situation objective économique et social
vous avez indiqué situation
d'amélioration mais parce que ce qui
depuis des siècles tient en france
ensemble des français c'est le rapport
au politique
c'est le politique qui est en crise les
français pour déployer leurs chili pour
qu'il ya un bonheur collectif des
français doivent avoir le sentiment
qu'ils maîtrisent leur destin qu'ils se
projettent dans le monde que c'est eux
qui nous sommes sur arte france depuis
napoléon à y compris jusqu'à moscou où
avant même les croisades le type de
rapport à la colonisation le type de
rapport à l'europe
les français doivent se dire que le
monde ait la france en grand or le
sommet de l'état bercy le logiciel
culturel de bercy de bruxelles et de
berna c'est tout l'inversé
le sommet de l'état demande à la nation
d'intérioriser le monde extérieur
alors que la france elle la nation a
besoin de se projeter à l'extérieur et
c'est selon moi cette raison éminemment
culturelle qui fait la dépression
française emmanuel macron semblait la
résoudre puisqu'il avait dit que le
problème c'était pas de français c'était
la classe politique un an après il
reprend le logiciel de bercy de
bruxelles qu'il avait lui-même dénoncé
la politique du rabot la politique des
3%
le fétichisme budgétaire donc selon moi
la dépression française a des raisons
culturelles avant tout et non pas
économique et social est ce que si on
vous suit ça sera ma dernière question à
ce que c'est un boulevard à l'avenir
pour les partis dit souverainiste entre
nîmes et populiste ça fait déjà de
nombreux mois que je pense qu'à ce
train-là évidemment puisque marine le
pen elle-même opère une mutation du
nationalisme à la nation on l'a bien vu
lors des européennes que le président
macron en cas de deuxième tour face à
marine le pen ne pourrait pas compter
sur le réflexe initial anti marine le
pen et c'est à mon avis par la
mésestimation de ça qu'il commet une
erreur de vouloir y aller au forceps
aidés par les institutions dans ses
réformes et et au fond dans l'idée que
la france n'aurait qu'à s'adapter au
monde extérieur ce qui est justement ce
qui entraîne en retour une volonté de
reprise en main de notre destin
autour de la question de la souveraineté
nationale merci beaucoup stéphane rozès
président de cap un poids votre analyse
merci à vous donc quelques instants
rester avec nos directions les états
unis où donald trump a dévoilé son plan
de paix au proche-orient saluée par
israël décrié par les palestiniens
et puis nous parlerons de la crise de
l'hôpital en france où les
démissions en série se multiplient
aujourd'hui 27 chef de service de
l'hôpital robert debré à paris sont
passés à l'acte
[Musique]
je serai votre sentiment sur les
mouvements concernant la manifestation
contre la retraite quand il ya autant de
travail qui a autant de chômeurs autant
de gens qui sont dans la logique comme
on dit aujourd'hui du burn out
est-ce qu'il n'y aurait pas à repenser
le travail c'est vraiment une question
philosophique pour moi je défends le
gilet jaune qui sont pour moi les les
sous prolétaires je défends également
ces gens là qui pour le coup ce sont les
prolétaires mais qui sont organisées
pourquoi est-ce que c'est toujours les
mêmes qui payent les pots plus modestes
et c est pourquoi ce sont toujours les
mêmes qui échappent soit à l'impôt soit
aux ponctions d'autres choses qui font
que s'il y avait vraiment un désir
d'équité
les français seraient produits éléments
plus à même de dire qu'il consente à ce
traitement est ce que vous avez compris
quelle était la revendication haut
niveau au moment des gilets jaunes tout
au départ ce sont juste des gens qui
disent si vous augmentez le prix du
carburant nous on va pas pouvoir des
gens disaient mais moi je suis chez mes
parents parce que je ne peux pas me
payer un loyer alors que je travaille
donc dès le départ c'était une
revendication de dignité mais vous avez
dit on n'a pas écouté ces gens là
comment voyez vous les écoutez puisque
personne ne prenait la parole et
personne n'était légitime pour
l'apprendre y en un qui est légitime
pour prendre la parole sur ce sujet là
ça s'appelle un président de la
république parce qu'il est investi de la
souveraineté nationale
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le lac 6 anti fait partie d'une réserve
naturelle à haute altitude
[Musique]
c'est là que le célèbre fleuve le site
arômes commence son voyage
c'est la principale voie navigable
d'indonésie
car le site a room est désormais une
fosse septique géante
le fleuve s'étend sur 300 kilomètres de
sa source à son embouchure et compte
plus de 2000 installations industrielles
réparties le long de ses rives
l'eau est devenue noire parce que les
déchets liquides de lusine ne sont pas
filtrer l'eau du site a room iric plus
de 4000 rizières et fournit de l'eau
potable à 25 millions de personnes
nous n'avons qu'un fleuve et c'est le
fleuve le plus polluées du monde
[Musique]
la crise de 2008 arrive et à ce moment
là on s'aperçoit que les choses ont été
mal faites
on n'avait aucunement prévu des
scénarios de crise de défaut de paiement
tant qu'on maintient la grèce avec les
mêmes conditions qui ont provoqué cette
crise vous aurez le même système
il serait plus cohérent qu'elle reprenne
son existence en main monnaie comprise
mais je reprendre sa monnaie ne résout
pas tout les tous les problèmes bien sûr
qu'il faut changer les hommes qui
dirigent parce que sinon vous ne
résoudrait rien en sortant de l'euro on
veut en fait forcé la marche du
transformation d'un prix donc
effectivement peut-être que certains
grecs ont envie de voir cette marche de
transformation du pays est sans aucun
doute une grande partie n'ont pas envie
de cette transformation son entrée dans
l'euro est en grande partie responsable
de ce qui lui arrivait
[Musique]
bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième heure d'émission tout de
suite voici les titres de l'actualité de
ce mardi un bail amis netanyahu salue
une journée historique le plan de paix
de donald trump pour le moyen-orient a
été dévoilé le président américain
évoque une solution réaliste à deux
états mais rappelle considérer jérusalem
comme la capitale indivisible de l'état
hébreu
washington annonce qu'elle va
reconnaître les colonies dans les
territoires palestiniens occupés comme
faisant partie d'israël un plan de paix
de 180 pages qui ne passera pas affirme
le président palestinien mahmoud abbas
nous en débattrons à 21h30
[Musique]
des heurts ont eu lieu aujourd'hui à
paris entre les forces de l'ordre et des
pompiers
ces derniers manifestaient à nouveau
pour exiger une revalorisation de leurs
conditions de travail notamment la prime
de feu et les questions de leur retraite
un mouvement de grève avait débuté en
juin mais la mobilisation est désormais
terminée après les annonces de
christophe castaner saluer donc par ce
dernier
l'hôpital public toujours en crise comme
annoncé il y a deux semaines à des
centaines de chefs de services
d'hôpitaux ont démissionné de leurs
fonctions administratives en cause
l'inaction de l'état mais aussi un
manque de moyens depuis mi janvier plus
de 1300 médecins ont annoncé leur
démission au niveau national
[Musique]
c'est donc un plan de paix de 180 pages
qui a été dévoilée par donald trump une
chance historique pour les palestiniens
d'obtenir un état indépendant selon le
président américain
on retrouve notre reporter thomas bonnet
en direct de tel aviv bonsoir
thomas le deal du siècle comme il est
présenté en tout cas par donald trump a
enfin été dévoilée après trois ans
élaboration
oui et ce qu'on retiendra d'abord ce
sont les images cette annonce d'un plan
de paix au proche orient avec donc
donald trump et benyamin nétanyahou un
plan de paix où une seule des deux
parties et présente ses dires le
déséquilibre déjà annoncé dès le début
de cette annonce
donald trump et benyamin nétanyahou qui
se sont montrés une nouvelle fois très
amicaux la envers l'autre très élogieux
avec beaucoup d'applaudissements
beaucoup de poignées de mains et de
congratulations entre les deux hommes
donald trump qui a ensuite commencé son
annonce en expliquant qu'il n'avait pas
été élu pour faire de petites choses et
qu'il s'agirait d'un processus long et
difficile il a ensuite donc a détaillé
ce fameux deal du siècle tels qu'ils
aiment le présenter en expliquant qu'il
souhaitait trouver une solution réaliste
à deux états on écoute le locataire de
la maison blanche
la vision présente une occasion gagnant
gagnant pour les deux parties une
solution réaliste at the series où le
risque représente un état palestinien
pour la sécurité d'israël
aujourd'hui israël fait un grand match
des world peace donald trump qui a
ensuite détaillé les différentes mesures
de ce plan de paix avec il faut bien le
dire plusieurs paradoxes d'abord il
explique qu'il veut faire de jérusalem
indivisible
la capitale de l'état d'israël mais dans
le même temps il promet aux palestiniens
de faire de jérusalem est la capitale de
l'état palestinien et même d'y installer
l'ambassade américaine voilà pour le
premier paradoxe l'autre grand paradoxe
c'est le fait que donald trump veut
appliquer la souveraineté d'israël dans
les territoires occupés et en même temps
il promet aux palestiniens de 12
bhl et les territoires palestiniens il a
également annoncé qu'il souhaitait
validé l'annexion de la vallée du
jourdain par l'état d'israël et en
contrepartie de tout cela donald trump
promet des investissements hauteur de 50
milliards de dollars en territoire
palestinien ce qui pourrait créer selon
lui un million d'emplois pour les
palestiniens
donald trump qui à la suite de son
annonce a publié une carte sur son
compte twitter une carte qui serait
selon lui le résultat de l'application
de ce plan de paix une carte qui va
évidemment être décortiqué à la loupe
par les différents observateurs benyamin
nétanyahou de son côté a ensuite pris la
parole il a qualifié ce jour d'
historique il explique que la solution
trouvée par donald trump et une
situation qui permet un bon équilibre et
il a donc rappelé le fait historique de
cette journée je propose d'écouter le
premier ministre israëlien deux stores
acteurs c'est un jour historique et il
m'en rappelle un autre
nous nous souvenons du 14 mai 1948
parce que ce jour là le président truman
est devenu le premier leader mondial à
reconnaître l'état d'israël après que
notre premier ministre david ben gourion
a déclaré notre indépendance
ils ont ouvert la porte à un avenir
radieux
monsieur le président je pense qu'au
cours des prochaines décennies et
peut-être au cours des prochains siècles
nous nous souviendrons également du 28
janvier 2020 car ce jour là vous êtes
devenu le premier leader mondial à
reconnaître la souveraineté d'israël sur
des zones comme la judée samarie qui
sont vitales pour notre sécurité et qui
sont au coeur de notre patrimoine
reste à voir maintenant si ce plan sera
applicable dans les faits ça semble
plutôt mal engagée puisque les
palestiniens rejettent en bloc les
propositions de donald trump et ce
malgré le fait que le locataire de la
maison blanche a expliqué qu'il fallait
trouver une solution où les deux parties
doivent être gagnante
ce n'est pas vraiment la vie
du côté des palestiniens ce soir merci
thomas bonnet en direct de tel aviv et
depuis la locution des présidents
américains et israéliens
les réactions internationales se
multiplient pour téhéran le plan de
donald trump est vouée à l échec un plan
mort-né pour ankara londres évoque une
proposition sérieuse qui pourrait être
une avancée alors que moscou appelle
israéliens et palestiniens à négocier
directement journée de manifestations en
france encore une autre pour les
pompiers cette fois qui annonce mettre
fin néanmoins ce soir à leur
mobilisation après les annonces de
christophe castaner ils ont notamment
obtenu une revalorisation salariale
maintien de leur système de retraite et
une augmentation de leurs primes de feu
de 6%
le ministre de l'intérieur salue la
décision des syndicats de mettre fin à
la grève ait des annonces du ministère
de l'intérieur après une manifestation
marquée par de nombreux heures cet après
midi dans la capitale plusieurs milliers
pompiers ont manifesté pour dénoncer le
manque de moyens et exiger le maintien
de leur système de retraite
trois interpellations étaient annoncés
retour en images sur les tensions de la
journée
et m
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
hier
aulas
[Musique]
g
et pour parler nous sommes avec yannick
tennessee secrétaire général du snspp
pts syndicat des pompiers professionnels
de france bonsoir yannick était dit
merci d'être avec nous alors vous vous
n'étiez pas sur cette manifestation
puisque vous étiez place beauvau avec le
ministre on l'a on va évidemment y
revenir sur ses revendications nous
avait d'ailleurs obtenu il ya plusieurs
jours déjà je voulais vous faire réagir
sur ces images de vos collègues même si
vous n'êtes pas forcément du même bord
syndicale avec les affrontements avec la
police avoue ne développe pas à ça
nourrir de toujours c'est toujours
choquant de voir qu'il peut ici avoir
des affrontements avec des gens avec
lesquels nous travaillons tous les jours
alors pas les crs mais tous les toutous
les services de police nous travaillons
avec eux tous les jours et de voir que
effectivement dans le cadre de maintien
de l'ordre
n'empêche les pompiers de dérivés de la
manifestation et que en face on n'a pas
toujours des enfants de choeur
effectivement les pompiers c'est des
gaillards aussi et puis il réagisse la
police eurent réagi ça donne
malheureusement ces scènes mais on peut
tenter de l'expliquer en résumant mais
comment comment on peut expliquer que
l'on a des pompiers et des policiers
vous le dites qui sont normalement
plutôt entre nîmes et ont parlé quand
c'est préfet de police qui parlait de
deux camps sont plutôt normalement dans
le même camp des fontes le maire voilà
au service du citoyen a priori qu'est ce
que ça dit
sur le climat actuel écoutez sursaut
climat je vais pas vous raconter
d'histoires c'est on a quand même des
sapeurs-pompiers qui sont un petit peu à
bout parce que ça fait depuis le mois de
juin que la majorité d'entre eux sont en
grève et puis ensuite toutes les
corporations syndicales en grève depuis
le mois d'août avec des avancées qui
n'étaient pas présentes et à un moment
où les pompiers ils en ont un peu assez
d'être baladées et ils vont finir par
avoir des gestes un petit peu des zeks
d'exaspération et puis montrer leur
mécontentement et on imagine la même
chose du côté des policiers qui on le
sait sont souvent présentés comme en
souffrance entre guillemets c'est toute
la fonction publique aujourd'hui qui
souffre effectivement non mais on est
tous là les les collègues policiers ont
exprimé depuis le mouvement des gilets
jaunes et même bien avant des
difficultés dans les effectifs des
difficultés donc à à faire leur travail
correctement à ne pas pouvoir poser
leurs jours de repos
bon tout ça c'est quelque chose qui va
qui va un petit peu tiré sûr sûr sûr le
sur le policier est sûre le pompier est
en fait c'est toute la souffrance de la
fonction publique en france
on peut parler des hôpitaux tout à
l'heure on n'est pas dans le même genre
on n'est pas sur le terrain entre
guillemets mais il accueille tout aux
urgences il accueille dans les hôpitaux
dans les cliniques et eux aussi sont en
souffrance et en sous-effectif c'est la
fonction publique qui va pas bien en
france
est ce que pour vous c'est une première
ça fait en temps j'imagine que vous êtes
dans dans ce métier est ce que ce climat
vous l'avez déjà ressenti aussi explosif
entre guillemets pour la fonction
publique non non non ça fait ça fait ça
fait depuis quelques mois quelques
années qu'on voit effectivement que les
leçons que la fonction publique est en
souffrance qu'on a toujours les mêmes
réponses que face à des mouvements de
grève qui viennent après la négociation
qui n'a jamais lieu finalement ou alors
cédé fin de non recevoir
on vous reçoit on vous dit que vous êtes
gentils on vous dit vous êtes mignon que
tout est légitime et on n'a pas l'argent
pour vous payer donc il arrive un moment
c'est bien légitime et puis on ne paye
pas et donc tout va est en souffrance a
créé des mouvements tels que les gilet
jaune
on laisse pourrir des situations on
laisse le mouvement s'étendre et puis
après un lundi on discrédite à cause de
la violence et c'est d'ailleurs quand on
voit des images de police pompiers ont
dit bastien et à la violence et puis
pour le coup on parle plus trop du fond
et c'est embêtant
nous on veut plus parler du fond que que
de ces quelques scènes qui puisse y
avoir mais effectivement c'est c'est un
mal être de la fonction publique que le
gouvernement les gouvernements
successifs parce que je ne veux pas
faire de politique ici je ne parle pas
de celui là mais aussi de tous ses
précédents ont laissé pourrir
pour finir une exaspération alors on va
parler du fond et aussi de quelques
bonne nouvelle parce que vous appelez ce
soir les pompiers y mettre fin
cette mobilisation ce mouvement de grève
vous vous étiez à la place beauvau
aujourd'hui racontez nous écoutez depuis
depuis une semaine le ministre de
l'intérieur nous avait écrit une
communication pour accepter le principe
d'une revalorisation de notre prime de
feu
sachant que nous redonne nous demandions
une prime de feu d'un taux de 2 28% et
qu'actuellement l'état 19% nous nous
avons eu une proposition de la monter à
25% et notre syndicat avait accepté ce
principe de revalorisation tout en se
disant que dans le futur on demanderait
finalement en alignement comme sur la
police par exemple avec leurs primes
spécifiques était un tube pour cent ont
demandé à peu près les mêmes choses et
on reviendra dessus plus tard dans les
années qui viennent parce que pour
l'instant se contente de 25% à cause des
difficultés budgétaires des
collectivités territoriales où on est
bien conscient qu effectivement ils vont
avoir du mal forcément toujours à
trouver des budgets et donc on est un
peu raisonnable et on se contente de 25%
pour le moment mais c'est ce sont des
éléments que nous avions depuis une
grosse semaine et c'est pour ça que
notre syndicat cet après midi n'avait
pas appelé à manifester et donc le
ministre nous a juste confirmé ce qu'il
écrit une semaine alors pourquoi votre
avis et manifestations deux de vos
collègues
aujourd'hui à paris alors bon il aurait
il leur appartient d'avoir voulu
jusqu'au jusqu'au bout de vouloir cette
prime à 28% et je me félicite que
finalement ils acceptent le principe de
le mettre à 25%
mais il reste cependant un
ddd chose sur lequel nous voulons
discuter notamment sur la fin de
carrière de sapeur-pompier parce que il
ya quand même encore des éléments qui
nous inquiète et peut-être aussi qu'il
avait voulu me cristalliser leur leur
mobilisation pour penser ce jeune en
vous revendiquez vous aviez des
revendications du côté du régime des
retraites où ça en est cette ce pan des
négociations écoutez les
sapeurs-pompiers sont rassurés sur un
point c'est qu'ils sont encore
considérés comme un métier dangereux
certes nous sommes depuis 2004 et les en
compte de la pénibilité dans votre cas
alors c'est pas tout à fait la
pénibilité que connaissent d'autres
salariés prévues dans le code du travail
on a vraiment un statut particulier où
on nous dit que nous sommes dans une
catégorie selon les propos du ministre
dans une catégorie active et dangereuse
et qu à ce rythme on va nous maintenir
une possibilité de départ anticipé
donc on pourra continuer de partir à 57
en retraite
toutefois on a une inquiétude sur le
fameux hd qui libre ou âges pivots que
le gouvernement compte bien mettre en
place pour toutes les catégories y
compris les sapeurs-pompiers et ça
voudrait dire qu'un pompier qui a toutes
ses annuités ne pourraient pas partir 57
ans sans décote et ça ça nous gêne et ça
vous n'avez pas été rassuré sur ce point
bien écouter on nous dit que c'est
encore en arbitrage que c'est pas fait
donc lorsque les décrets d'application
sortiront pour cette catégorie active et
dangereuse on nous consultera dont acte
j'aime à penser que l'on fera fléchir la
position du gouvernement là dessus parce
que c'est vraiment inacceptable dans le
cadre de quelqu'un qui réalise un métier
dangereux de laisser sur le terrain
alors qu'il a déjà tous et hannut et il
ya d'autres dates de négociation qui
sont prévus d'autres rendez-vous alors
pas sur ce sujet là sur les retraites et
d'ailleurs il passera la main
au secrétaire d'état qui gère les
retraites ce sera plus lui qui gérera ce
dossier merci beaucoup et yannick nazis
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur arte
france merci à vous autres grogne on en
parlait à l'instant meilleur le
collectif inter hôpitaux qui a mis sa
menace à exécution ce mardi 27 chef de
service de l'hôpital robert debré ont
démissionné de leurs fonctions
administratives pour défendre le service
public hospitalier
hier une cinquantaine dit une
cinquantaine de médecins et de chefs de
service du chu de rennes avait déjà
présenté leur démission le point avec
sébastien dufour et david luiz inouïe
augmentation du budget et des salaires
voici leurs principales revendications
depuis dix mois les personnels soignant
s'inquiète de l'état de santé de
l'hôpital public
nouveau signe de cette montée de tension
les fermetures de lits et le manque de
personnel qui touche aujourd'hui tous
les services les démissions s'enchaînent
ce matin ce sont une vingtaine de chefs
de service de l'hôpital robert debré à
paris qui ont mis leur menace à
exécution
toutes les personnes qui participent aux
soins dans cet hôpital sont là pour
soutenir les chefs de service dans cet
acte symbolique et qui sont en train de
faire parce qu'on n'est pas entendue
parce que on n'a pas de soutien et que
on est là à pour nous on est là pour
pouvoir continuer à soigner
c'est un geste
inattendu j'avais été pratiquée jusqu'à
présent est ce que ça sera suffisant
on l'espère c'est du moins
l'espoir d'être entendus au moins une
fois par nos instances
au niveau national plus de 1300 médecins
ont annoncé leur départ depuis
mi-janvier les démissionnaires ne vont
plus participer aux réunions qui ne sont
pas directement liées aux soins des
patients à la recherche et à
l'enseignement
c'est un geste inédit et bouleversant
pour nous pour exprimer à quel point le
défaut d' écoute de ce gouvernement
comme des précédents est devenu graves
dans le fonctionnement de tous les jours
à ma connaissance c'est effectivement
une première ça représente 75 % des
chefs de service d'une unité
fonctionnelle de l'ensemble de l'hôpital
on est dans une situation inédite par le
fait qu'on refuse de tenir compte de nos
revendications qui sont vous les
connaissez bien l'augmentation du
financement de la santé par
l'augmentation de l'ondam et surtout la
revalorisation de tous les salaires de
la fonction publique
syndicats et collectifs de soignants
appelle désormais à une nouvelle journée
de mobilisation le 14 février pour
exiger que le gouvernement ouvre de
véritables négociations
le 14 novembre dernier un médecin
hospitalier sur quatre et plus de 10% du
personnel paramédical avaient battu le
pavé partout en france et pour en parler
nous sommes avec stéphane dauger et chef
du service de réanimation pédiatrique à
l'hôpital robert debré bonsoir
dauger merci d'être avec nous vous avez
déjà vu intervenir dans ce sujet je vous
avais été rouvier il ya quelques jours
vous menaciez effectivement de
démissionner ça y est vous êtes passés
aux actes on imagine que ça a été une
décision extrêmement compliqué difficile
à prendre pour vous bonsoir madame oui
effectivement une décision difficile ça
fait à peu près un mois que nous étions
avec nos équipes à en discuter que nous
avons prévenu que nous en avons parlé
avec notre direction que nous avons même
rencontré la ministre il ya quinze jours
lors de nos menaces et ça a été
compliqué d'arriver jusqu'à ce matin
l'état d'esprit des collègues était une
très très grande motivation nous étions
donc nous sommes donc 28 même ses 75 %
des chefs de service de l'hôpital à
avoir porté notre démission
un autre directeur c'est une décision
lourde longuement réfléchi mais qui est
qui est effectivement très compliqué
alors 27 chefs de service dans un
hôpital on imagine mal les conséquences
ça va être très compliqué pour cet
hôpital qu elles peuvent être la suite
l'issue de ces démissions
alors très compliqué on insiste bien sur
le fait que nous sommes médecins pour
certains chercheurs ou en plus
enseignants ou les trois à la fois et
ses missions là il est hors de question
de les arrêter et en tout premier lieu
le soin bien évidemment nous
participerons à l'activité habituelle de
nos services dans les équipes auxquelles
nous appartenons
par contre c'est à l'administration que
nous faire passer le message de faire
remonter à nos tutelles et je pense
maintenant au premier ministre à
monsieur le président de la république
on peut plus avancer comme ça qu'il faut
mettre tout de suite sur la table les
quatre revendications principales du cih
et c'est cela notre objectif c'est de
rajouter à la grèce de la facturation
dont nous avions déjà parlé sur cette
antenne ya quelques semaines ce geste
fort sur tout le territoire pour
qu'enfin on puisse débattre est avancé
pour l'hôpital public est votre espoir
de vous faire entendre puisque
manifestement la ministre n'a pas
entendu elle vous a laissé aller jusqu'à
la démission alors qu'elles étaient
parfaitement au courant de votre menace
qu'elle porte de sortie quelles chances
de réussite pour vous et pour l'hôpital
selon vous je pense que là on a atteint
les chefs de service continue à signer
les menaces de démission
donc on a parlé des 1320 mais on doit
être à plus maintenant puisque une
dizaine à peu près sûr plus territoires
outre-mer universitaire universitaire
quelles que soient les structures des
chefs continue à signer je pense quand
même qu'on va atteindre quasiment les 15
% de l'ensemble des chefs de service de
l'hôpital public
j'ose espérer que notre gouvernement va
entendre ce cri d'alarmé
en plus de tous ceux qui ont été
prononcées depuis longtemps nous restons
très motivés nous restons dans l' envie
d'avancer
il est hors de question de fermer la
porte au contraire on attend que ça
qu'on puisse se poser pour débattre et
avancer sur nos principales
revendications mettre en place des
négociations si nécessaire sans aucun
problème j'en appelle et nous en
appelons tout ça
l'état du gouvernement et puis au
premier ministre et au président de la
république pour que effectivement ils
entendent ce cri d' allah on sait les
dernières chances de l'hôpital public
on y croit dur comme fer si nous avons
fait ce geste très symbolique qui nous a
coûté beaucoup à nos équipes et à nous
c'est pour faire passer ce message fort
et on reste très motivé on va y arriver
on en a déjà parlé évidemment très
souvent ici sur notre chaîne
mais pour nos téléspectateurs peut-être
qu'il n'aurait pas suivi on rappelle vos
négociations vraiment principale cell
peut-être que vous obtiendrez
pour justement arrêter ce mouvement
quelles sont elles
alors les principales sont toujours les
mêmes depuis déjà de nombreux mois comme
vous l'avez dit la première c'est une
nouvelle autorisation du financement de
l'hôpital public
on attend le geste fort bien au delà que
de ce qui avait été présenté mi novembre
encore une fois ce sont des
recommandations très forte de
différentes instances dont la cour des
comptes on veut effectivement ne pas
replacer instantanément l'hôpital public
dans une dette dès les premiers mois
d'exercice 2020 donc là il ya un geste
fort à faire pour ensuite commencer une
négociation avec le gouvernement
la deuxième de nos motivations et de nos
revendications c'est celle des tout
petits salaires de la fonction publique
hospitalière des soignants et non
soignants
on est dans une situation absolument
catastrophique par rapport à de nombreux
autres pays de notre niveau général et
ne peut pas avancer comme ça
la troisième c'est la couverture de lits
dans les secteurs qui en ont besoin
et là encore le rôle du chef de service
nous l'avons écrit comme tel défendu
comme tel dans sa position permet de
savoir exactement quels sont les lits
dont l'hôpital a forcément besoin
là encore ce rôle est central et la
quatrième sur lequel on a vu peut-être
des petites avancées mais qui pour
l'instant ne nous satisfont pas encore
on vient de le vivre la science publique
récemment avec des menaces sur les
paroles et paramédicaux très forte
ne serait-ce que vendredi dernier c'est
un changement de gouvernance est plus un
directeur qui ne regarde que les
finances de l'hôpital mais un rébus
directeur qui regardent en premier lieu
les besoins de santé de la population en
tenant compte des coûts bien évidemment
et là dedans dans cette manière de gérer
l'hôpital les soignants et non soignants
les usagers doivent prendre un rôle
majeur c'est notre quatrième
revendications
merci beaucoup stéphane augé d'avoir été
en direct avec nous au chef du service
de réanimation pédiatrique à l'hôpital
robert degré debré après donc ces
démissions en cascade
aujourd'hui merci à vous dans quelques
instants notre débat sur le plan de paix
du proche-orient dévoilée par donald
trump ti d'être une réussite nous en
débattrons avec nos invités dans
quelques instants
[Musique]
si on chantait mais rioux bah tu dis
quoi une chanson d'ado bercy le 6 mois y
est collé be cruel et yoyo libye
envoyez vos paniers honte
le pitch au dalo guirassy
brian baloyi coda
à tous d'avis au canada
à ceux-là je chante beaucoup aujourd'hui
[Musique]
la planète terre dans un futur proche
les mêmes qasmi si un débris spatial
robert f
quoique hausse touche un satellite d'un
pays mange cela pourrait engendrer un
conflit autour de la terre l'espace est
polluée
il dérive en orbite d'innombrables
débris des millions de fragments de
tailles variées incontrôlable il est
extrêmement difficile de les suivre tous
orangina les accidents vont se
multiplier les vols habités risque de
devenir trop dangereux et les
communications par satellite vont se
détériorer les systèmes de navigation
gps pourrait devenir de moins en moins
fiables internet auquel nous sommes tous
tellement habitués pourrait
dysfonctionné et perdre en vitesse
le gadget préféré le confort de la haute
technologie tout cela pourrait devenir
totalement inutilisable
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes c'est diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même et
qui va repousser l'état islamique si je
me bats pas si les autres se battent pas
[Musique]
après les combats pour serrer cani je me
suis dit s'il n'y avait pas de y est j
qu'est-ce qui nous serait arrivé je vais
combattre l'ennemi pour que mon père
soit en sécurité et qu'ils soient fiers
de moi
[Musique]
elles sont venues ici pour défendre leur
terre et combattre dèche
[Musique]
il a raison des morts et notre vie c'est
à l'état islamique d'avoir peur de nous
car nous n'avons peur de personne
[Musique]
je
21h30 soyez les bienvenus en direct sur
rt france merci de nous rejoindre avant
ce nouveau plan de paix américain sept
tentatives ont déjà été menées par la
communauté internationale et plus
particulièrement les etats-unis se sont
toutes soldées par des échecs regarder
[Musique]
on
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un plan de paix pour le proche-orient
donc dévoilé par le président américain
fondé sur une solution à deux états et
dans lequel israël obtient de nombreuses
concessions alors que donald trump
affiche son optimisme les palestiniens
eux continuent de le rejeter
alors ce plan est il déjà vous l échec
c'est l'objet de notre face à face ce
soir et pour en débattre nous sommes sur
ce plateau avec bernard ravenel
historien auteur de la résistance
palestinienne des armes à la non
violence aux éditions l'harmattan en
direct donc sur ce plateau par skype en
direct de tel aviv jacques benillouche
journaliste indépendant bonsoir jacques
benillouche merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france j'invite donc nos
deux invités à débattre à distance alors
donald trump pour l'adie qui a affiché
un optimisme sur la réussite de ce plan
hier à ce que vous partagez le même
optimisme ce soir après donc les
événements de ce plan c'est vraiment
difficile
je crois qu'on assistait au
franchissement d'une ligne rouge
internationale qui était en quelque
sorte l'existence de la palestine telle
qu'elle était reconnu par les nations
unies un cas de la cisjordanie et de
gaza et pour lequel la frontière était
là là la ligne la ligne verte et pour
lequel finalement il y avait aucune
discussion concernant la légitimité de
cette ligne verte
aujourd'hui pousser mais en même temps
par évidemment le président netanyahu il
ya ce franchissement
on assiste à une dernière étape
peut-être de la conquête de la palestine
historique
quelle qu'elle était un moment envisagé
par le par le mouvement sioniste début
du 20e siècle
donc il ya quelque chose là un événement
historique je pense extrêmement grave
jacques benillouche
votre analyse sur ce diagnostic de
bernard à venelles oui c'est un
diagnostic que je partage pas beaucoup
parce que d'abord ce que je voulais dire
c'est que ce plan n'a rien de nouveau
nous avons perdu 52 ans parce que le 27
juillet 1967
le ministre du travail de l'époque ygal
allon ministre socialiste du
gouvernement levi eshkol tu avais
présenté exactement ce plan à quelques
ep si lon près il a été rejeté
j'ai reçu tout à l'heure la carte que
nous a envoyé donald trump gelé mise
face à la carte des galas l'one et on se
retrouve exactement dans les mêmes
conditions
ça c'est un point factuel moi je vais me
positionner sur des points factuel je ne
suis pas un membre d'aucun parti
je suis journaliste j'analyse et donc je
me base sur des faits moi ce que je
voudrais dire c'est que là les
palestiniens ont raté plusieurs
occasions
plusieurs occasions à chaque occasion
ratée
israël a augmenté sa taille la première
occasion ratée c'est en 1937
c'était le plan pile anglais qui avait
proposé de partager de créer deux états
et israël récupérer cinq mille
kilomètres carrés de terrain ça a été
refusé par les arabes en 47 le plan de
l'onu le vote de l'onu attribué aux deux
et a attribué à israël une base de 10
mille kilomètres carrés en 48 à la suite
des attaques arabes contre israël et de
la guerre d'indépendance
israël s'est retrouvé à occuper vingt
mille kilomètres carrés dont vrai que
chaque refus entraîne en 67 après la
guerre de fer par an après la guerre des
six jours
eh bien on a ajouté toute la cisjordanie
à israël
et ça elle s'est retrouvée avec 26 mille
kilomètres carrés
donc chaque refus arabe à entraînent la
croissance du 2 2
l'état d'israël donc moi ça c'est une
constatation ce n'est pas une autre
chose
moi ce que je voudrais dire aujourd'hui
c'est que on croit que cette ce plan se
partagent plan de partage de donald
trump n'est que trop israélien moi je
peux donner plusieurs exemples et
plusieurs cas pour dire qu'en fait c'est
le premier ministre netanyahu est forcé
de remanier d'avaler des couleuvres
d'ailleurs je pense on va le voir demain
je pense que beaucoup de deux
politiciens de droite vont hurler au
problème à un os à ce plan de partage je
donnerai deux cas simplement deux points
premier point
jérusalem sera partagée donald trump a
dit que jérusalem sera partagée pour les
deux états israël et la palestine
or pendant longtemps on a dit et les
appelait les nationalistes juifs disait
israël et indivisible ça c'est un
premier point et deuxième point nous
nous retrouvons à avoir des relations
avec des zones qui sont pas autorisés
c'est à dire qu'en fait que on va on va
pas accepter l'année l'annexion pure et
simple comme natanyahou lundi trump a
autorisé simplement l'annexion de
certains territoires
or natanyahou vous les indexer la
totalité de ces territoires dont d'état
ou n'a pas gagné dans ce domaine donc je
donne simplement deux exemples je
pouvais en donner beaucoup d'autres
beaucoup d'autres
mais ceci pour dire que c'est quand même
pas une victoire totale de natanyahou ce
n'est pas une victoire totale de je
dirais de la droite c'est simplement que
ils ont fait des concessions
et dans le fond c'est pas mauvais qu'ils
fassent des concessions
on ne peut avancer que s'il ya des
concessions de part et d'autres par
contre ce que je ne comprends pas c'est
que les palestiniens refusent ce plan se
refuse blanc et on va se retrouver à
chaque fois à une avancée de d'israël
qui va encore gagner du terrain
il va on va écouter on a bien compris le
message jacques benillouche on va
écouter la réponse de bernard ravenel
vous allez répondre peut-être point par
point mais alors moi c'est vrai que
j'avais une interrogation jacques
benillouche à évoquer cette histoire de
capital alors donald trump a quand même
rappelé le caractère indivisible
jérusalem la capitale indivisible
d'israël at il dit mais on évoquant dans
le même temps une capitale pour les a
pas laissés pour les palestiniens de
jérusalem-est alors c'est vrai que ça je
peux peut-être de j'attends vos lumières
sur ce point l'un et l'autre ne
s'appelle pas concrètement et je vous
laisse effectivement répondre à jacques
benillouche qui dit à chaque fois à
chaque fois les palestiniens en faire du
compte ils ont refusé c'est l'analyse en
tout cas de jacques benillouche non j'ai
bien compris la situation actuelle et la
décision de l'épreuve et cetera c'est la
faute aux arabes
je voudrais quand même qu'on limite un
petit peu cette observation
parce qu'en réalité aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce que obtient des ténias où il
obtient une sorte de feu vert pour
commencer continuer à conquérir la
cisjordanie
en commençant par la vallée du jourdain
c'est ça l'événement en quelque sorte
factuel aussi considérable qui va en
quelque sorte franchir une étape
à mon avis tout à fait décisive dans la
nature du conflit une femme de neuf
juges pas si on peut parler de ça mais
c'est une poursuite de la colonisation
puisqu'on va accepter de reconnaître la
légitimité des colonies et de sacs à
main phénomène extraordinaire
donc c'est la continuation la
légitimation de la colonisation de
l'ensemble de la palestine de fait et en
plus sans parler du golan qui
appartenait el al asiri donc trouvé que
à ce moment là un et ayew a fait des
concessions
c'est absolument remarquable parce qu'en
réalité les natanyahou quelque sorte à
gagner quel est le problème derrière
aussi c'est un problème politique que
les deux protagonistes se trompent
qu'alitalia ou ont derrière eux c'est à
dire et le problème du netanyahu c'est
de gagner gagner les élections et titre
up soutien netanyahu dans cette
perspective de la future élection qui
auront lieu en israël
c'est ça le l'enjeu politique immédiat
et donc de ce point de vue là je suis à
yahoo a gagné à gagner le problème java
est ce qui va gagner les élections c'est
un autre sujet mais enfin c'est un coup
de plus tout à fait considérable et très
significatif très significatif et que
donc je considère que dit
que là la situation finalement fait que
les palestiniens auraient tort de ne pas
accepter ce plan ou d'en discuter
on est le problème c'est qu'on les a
jamais consultés sur cette question va
peut-être regarder la carte 4,8 et un
lui-même donald trump qui serait
effectivement la nouvelle carte jacques
benillouche haut sur ce point
effectivement donald trump
en gros les etats-unis qui sont prêts à
reconnaître la souveraineté israélienne
sur des territoires occupés mais c'est
de manière un petit peu unilatérale
est-ce qu'on peut finalement accepté
qu'un accord comme ça soit acceptée
alors qu'on dessine les choses de
manière unilatérale je filais pas
d'accord une seat perciot ya une
situation de fait il faut le dire on ne
que voulez vous qu'on fasse on envoie
des troupes expulser tous les juifs 600
milles entre 500 mille six cent mille
qui sont aujourd'hui installés dans ces
territoires
donc c'est quelque chose qui est
impossible à envisager et aucun
d'américains aucun israélien acceptera
cette situation donc je reviens sur ce
que je disais il faut être pragmatique
moi je pense que si des négociations
avancent il est fort probable que les
les idées de avigdor lieberman le
nationalisme pur et dur qui a mis de
l'eau dans sa vodka je dirais et bien ce
que propose lieberman ces deux dodos
free entre guillemets toute une bande de
terre où il y a une dizaine de villages
arabes israéliens qui colle la frontière
qui colle la ligne verte de offrir toute
cette terre-là pour caen pas compensé la
terre qu'ils auront pris en cisjordanie
c'est à dire qu'on donnerait en gros un
territoire arabe contre un territoire
éventuellement juifs
donc il y a des possibilités il ya des
possibilités de négociation dont on n'a
pas fini ça sur ce point fait répond non
mais ça c'est le vieux projet de
le lieberman le problème c'est que
d'abord sur la consulter les populations
concernées sur la population à consulter
les représentants de surpopulation et
j'ai pas l'impression que cet effet j'ai
toujours une pratique unilatérale de
virer les les arabes d'israël pour faire
distraire quelque sorte un état juif
d'engagement et georges lire pu en tant
qu il met donc il ya berlin je sais que
les palestiniens sont exclues de tout
débat de toute négociation alors les y
participe a bien sûr on est ce que tu es
ce que tu feras pas consulté a vu le
mahmoud abbas c est absolument avec
sardines l'être dit-il une lettre dont
quasiment que son plan était une chance
expliqué que le territoire prévu pour
son nouvel état resteraient ouverts et
sans développement de colonies
israéliennes pendant une période de
quatre ans voilà ce qu'a dit donald
trump à mahmoud abbas
aujourd'hui politiquement ce café
netanyahu at note n'a jamais été en
quelque sorte condamné par la communauté
internationale en particulier est
évident que nous tirions veut faire ce
qu'il veut parce qu'il y aura une
impunité est ce qu'il fait et donc je
crois que demain pour le gault lent donc
il ya toute cette histoire qui est
derrière
il faut pas faire croire que il y a une
perspective ouverte de paix négociée
parce que finalement les pellets cia
sont encore à rougir de perdre une
grande partie encore de leur territoire
reconnu par la communauté internationale
par le droit international
donc on est plus à 22% on va diminuer
encore les pourcentages octroyé si on
peut dire aux palestiniens
moi cette carte l'avait fait penser en
quelque chose aux bantoustans d'afrique
du sud ya quelque chose qui est on
dirait un direct des américains n'ont
pas ou n'ont pas appris de l'histoire de
ce qui s'est passé en afrique du sud ya
quelque chose de pathétique finalement
dans cette dans cette histoire qui aussi
est un peu dramatique pour l'ensemble de
la région
comment pouvez vous expliquer que
plusieurs pays arabes étaient présents à
la à la présentation du plan plusieurs
pays arabes et la jordanie et les
émirats arabes unis et d'autres encore
comment expliquer que beaucoup de pays
arabes sont prêts à se faire le pas
alors on va dire ce sont des
impérialistes aurait bien que ce sont
des des gens non démocrates
il ya quand même certains pays qui
estiment qu'il faut cesser et qu'on ne
peut pas continuer à faire la guerre
parce que la guerre n'apportera rien la
guerre n'apportera rien politiquement
aux palestiniens et la pandera que les
malheurs donc je pense personnellement
et je suis comme vous un amoureux de la
paix moi je pense qu'il faut que les
gens s'asseyent sur la base d'un blanc
ce plan là n'est pas définitif
ce blond est et a été proposé aux deux
parties qui doivent maintenant s'asseoir
discuter et vous savez que nous sommes
au moyen-orient et les marchandages
marche très bien
la compo de marchandage messieurs il ya
quelque chose de très important dont on
n'a pas encore parlé dans ce plan c'est
les soi-disant un million d'emplois
vanté par donald trump 1,50 milliard de
dollars dans des territoires qui qui
souffrent économiquement bernard à
venelles pour vous situer ce vieux vieux
temps de la paix économique qui ne
marche jamais on a on a dansé d'aller
couper la france a tenté avec des
algériens avec le banc de touche tantine
paix économique en valeur relative
c'est pas ça que veulent les
palestiniens et veulent reconnaissent
qu'on reconnaisse leurs droits c'est ça
qu'est leur dignité politique
donc je pense que c'était un leurre qui
est fin d'année et puis quand on
concernant le soutien à des états arabes
à israël c'est pas la première fois que
les états d'abord il ya étudié jack
arabie saoudite
c'est pas la première fois que j'étais
arabes n'ont jamais soutenu vraiment les
palestiniens et ça c'est un situe
malheureusement c'est le drame des
palestiniens c'est pas varité soutenue
de fait par les états arabes et ça fait
partie de l'évolution de la situation
encore encore plus grave donc faire
croire qu'il est arabe comme soutenu ce
projet est un aspect positif au népal
vient pas du tout pas du tout des
populations arabes
les petits étaient libres s'exprimer
dans le monde arabe refuserait c'est ce
qui va se passer d'ailleurs je pense et
mais malheureusement j exprime pas
forcément à commencer par ce qu'il va se
passer je pense en jordanie
parce que là nous avons une situation
qui va être un petit peu délicate c'est
le moins qu'on puisse dire jamais
comment peut réagir le reste du monde
parce qu'on a déjà vu les premières
réactions longue qui parle d'avancés
moss
qui appelle israël n'est pas destiné à
négocier directement l'egypte qui
appelle israéliens dans le même temps à
d'ailleurs et palestiniens à examiner ce
plan de manière attentif et approfondir
le rôle des autres pays a entre
guillemets va être important et crucial
moi je voudrais je voudrais rebondir sur
une question importante c'est la paix
par l'économie vous devez savoir
qu'aujourd'hui il y à l'équivalent de
150 mille ouvriers palestiniens qui
traversent la frontière de cisjordanie
pour venir travailler en israël
sans ces ouvriers là il n'y aurait plus
de construction en israël il n'y aurait
plus de ramassage des légumes
il n'y aurait plus même dans certains
cas de traces de travaux de travaux
publics
donc je dis que les palestiniens sont
prêts à collaborer à l'heure actuelle
les leurres hamas est en négociations
secrètes avec israël via l'egypte ait
leur âme à celle de nos demandes
justement à ce qu'il y ait des ouvriers
palestiniens qui rentrent en israël et
on a accepté sous une forme déguisée
on a accepté qu'ils et 10000 20000 qui
se retire entre qui sont d'ailleurs à
l'heure actuelle la qui travaillent
cela veut dire qu'il peut y avoir un
échange le la cisjordanie et gaza
c'est un vivier de main d'oeuvre israël
a beaucoup de problèmes de mal d'heures
c'est un petit pays qui n'a pas
suffisamment de main d'oeuvre est donc
celle là on peut alors certains vont
dire oui mais on va pas contre que de
l'amateur il ya aussi vous devez savoir
que la moitié des médecins en israël
sont des arabes
la moitié des pharmaciens sont des
hameaux médecin est un médecin rap quand
je vais dans ma pharmacie
c'est un arabe qui me sert donc dire que
il n'ya il y a un problème entre les
arabes et israël je dis que c'est non et
à l'heure actuelle vous pouvez le
vérifier il y à des négociations
secrètes leur hamas est prêt à signer un
accord de paix avec israël
sa poupe à l'heure actuelle il ya
simplement à petit une petite question
qui bloque c'est une question d'une
personne le ramasse imposé déjà les
comptes
d'ailleurs le paradoxe il le ramasse
impose que marca que à marwan barghouti
l'ancien chef du fatah soit libéré dans
un échange de deux prisonniers
c'est quand même étonnant que le ramasse
demande à ce qu'un gars du fatah soit
libéré ça veut dire on va écouter la
réponse de bernard ravenel respecter le
temps de parole si j'ose dire les choses
sont moins pire que ce qu'on veut bien
nous présenter ici
sur le terrain manifestement selon lui
le problème c'est que y compris si on
veut faire la comparaison que j'aime pas
tellement avec l'afrique du sud
l'afrique du sud le régime avait besoin
de la main d'oeuvre
moi à l'époque elle est d'ailleurs ils
étaient autorisés à passer avec un
système de contrôle de même d'ailleurs
que l'aller les palestiniens de
cisjordanie antisthène de contrôle assez
terry pour patients d'israël passons
mais est ce que je crois c'est pas ça
que demandent les les parisiens et
demande à voir une souveraineté une une
fin de l'occupation israélienne sur leur
pays sur leurs populations sur leur
territoire c'est ça et c'est ça qu'ils
n'obtiennent pas un rond contraire ça va
s'aggraver donc je pense que on détourne
de sujet on détourne le problème en
quelque sorte en ne parlant pas de la
fin de l'occupation militaire et des
lacs est le signe de la cud et la fin de
la présidence était la tutelle
israélienne sur sur la palestine et qui
va être quelque chose à graver et
légitime et pas par patrons non je crois
que et je crois qu'on se trouve de
débats je crois qu'aujourd'hui la
question est celle de l'établissement
d'un état palestinien souverain autonome
indépendant de toute pression de toute
souveraineté israélienne et ça s'est vu
refuser ce refuge est d'ailleurs semaine
a refusé notre manière de dire que c'est
la seule chance pour les palestiniens
d'obtenir un état indépendant vous n'y
croyez pas du tout mais moi aussi je
pourrais y est quoi ce serait bien parce
que ce fait des années que ce sera pour
un état de palestine
on est on négocie même pas avec ceux qui
se comportent ils représentent
aujourd'hui alors faire croire que ça va
être plus tard eux-mêmes qui va être
l'état palestinien est une véritable
plaie gens trient malheureusement
dramatique pour les palestiniens
nous sommes au début d'une phase
politique que nouvelle moyen-orient qui
était caractérisé par le fait que la
question palestinienne n'est pas résolu
n'est pas résolu et que les palestiniens
vont été obligé d'incitation de
de révolte jeu supplémentaire faut
s'attendre à des formes de soulèvements
relativement dramatique et moi je suis
très inquiet pour ça parce que netanyahu
est capable de faire la guerre comme
vous le savez et et d'autre part puisque
le hamas semble vouloir négocier avec
israël a eu un rôle très important dans
la création d amasser très bien démontré
et qu'est la grande réussite d'israël
c'est d'avoir divisé et compris la
représentation palestinienne entre le
hamas et le fatah est que aujourd'hui
vouloir négocier séparément avec l'une
des deux parties pour empêcher justement
l'union des deux forces tu pour négocier
en tant que représentant de l'ancien des
palestiniens c'est effectivement un
grand succès pour israël et c'est une
grande défaite pour les policiers il
faut bien il faut bien reconnaître et ça
veut dire aussi ça veut dire aussi qu'il
n'y aura pas de reconnaissance d'un état
palestinien souverain sur les 10 et sur
ce qui est prévu par le droit
international c'est à dire sur les 22 %
de la chaîne paris celle historique
c'était ça l'enjeu la ligne verte qu'il
veut absolument maintenant viol et de
toute manière et qui va l'être dans les
jours qui viennent dans les mois qui
viennent par là par le gouvernement
israélien style italien où est réélu
très rapidement le mot de la fin
ce qu'on arrive à la fin de ce débat
vous craignez aussi la réaction vous des
palestiniens que quand bernard ravenel
avec éventuellement un embrasement
je ne veux pas trahir les secrets de
belencontre
j'ai beaucoup de rencontres avec des
arabes palestiniens qui traversent la
frontière de temps en temps nous
rencontrons dans une ville palestinienne
de temps en temps c'est eux qui traverse
en ayant le droit de traverser ce que je
peux vous dire c'est qu'ils sont tous
unanimes à rechercher cette paix quand
je leur dis mais enfin dix mois
qu'est ce qui se passe chez vous comment
se fait-il que vous n'arrivez pas à
obtenir quoi que ce soit de la part de
votre direction
il me dit mais mahmoud abbas détient les
clés détient les clés du coffre fort
sans argent nous ne pouvons rien faire
c'était comme ça hier avec yasser arafat
aujourd'hui c'est pareil donc si jamais
on veut faire la révolution
eh bien on n'obtiendra rien c'est pour
ça que c'est
solution 1 n'arrivent pas encore en
cisjordanie mais ce qu'ils veulent c'est
avoir des bonnes relations avec israël
gagner de l'argent et avoir une bonne
solution de paix donc moi
personnellement qui ne suit pas
va-t-en guerre est bien j'estime que
c'est en discutant en émotions en
échangeant des idées et ne pas en scène
ne s'attaquant pas que nous pouvons
obtenir quelque chose
la paix par l'économie j'y crois
beaucoup et je ne suis pas le seul à y
croire
il suffit de savoir que quand un ouvrier
vient travailler en israël
il fait vivre quatre familles et c'est
pour ça que quand il ya 100 107 100 à
150 milles
le travailleur qui rentrent en israël
ces six cent mille familles qui vivent
grâce à israël
et ce sont des gens que je côtoie tous
les jours dans la rue parce que chez
nous il y à des travaux partout là dans
ma résidence des gens construisent des
balcons je les vois je discute avec eux
ils savent nous sachons un ancien ancien
de tunisie non je dirais connaissant les
arabes
eh bien ils acceptent de parler avec moi
et disent la vérité
ils disent malheureusement nous n'avons
pas de bons dirigeants mais nous nous
sommes prêts nous venons nous
travaillons ici et nous ne ferons rien
pour nous compte pour qu'on nous empêche
de rentrer en israël et donner de
l'argent et donner de la nourriture à
nos enfants qui est certains disent même
nous voulons qu'ils aillent à
l'université israélienne
parce que pour nous c'est le meilleur
moyen de pouvoir créer un état libre
merci c'est long mais ça sera pour vous
le mot de la fin que la petite
conclusion sur ce bateau à paris mais en
tout cas je lirai 2 2 phrases si on peut
dire l'histoire de la décolonisation
monde qu'on n'a jamais gagné la paix en
faisant quelque sorte une oeuvre un
aspect économique qui sans régler la
question politique
dès l'indépendance des peuples colonisés
deuxièmement je crois que la défaillance
maintenance des états unis pour faire
respecter le droit international et donc
les droits compris les palestiniens
oblige maintenant l'union européenne
cette institution laquelle n'a pas
répondu chacun je vous réponds
maintenant je pense que maintenant c'est
l'union européenne d'avoir une
initiative y compris pour une conférence
internationale qui serait réunie et qui
serait fondée sur la question du droit
international en liaison avec l'onu je
pense qu elle pas d'autres perspectives
aujourd'hui et je crois que jacques
benillouche alors remet çà mau je dis
simplement que l'europe est absente et
je leur rends fait ce qu'on lui reproche
et je le regrette et je regrette que
l'absorbent que la france soit absente
et je regrette que la france n'est pas
un rôle de d'arbitrage
je fais tout avec les ambassadeurs quand
je les rencontre
je leur dit toujours cela la france doit
intervenir comme comme arbitre et la
france et si on a compris mais
interviennent ressentez leur but
merci en tout cas tous les deux pour ce
débat nourri ma mère à venelles jacques
benillouche à tel aviv merci à vous deux
on se retrouve dans trois petites
minutes même pas pour un nouveau journal
[Musique]
et
c'est quoi pour vous fils république
éthique écoutez c'est une république qui
se préoccupent de lutter contre la
corruption et contre la fraude fiscale
qui a conscience que c'est un enjeu
considérable
le coût de la corruption et est évalué à
pour la france chaque année à 120
milliards le coût de la fraude fiscale
entre 80 et 100 milliards chaque année
évidemment cet argent pourrait être
beaucoup mieux employé dans une affaire
pin up fillion la classe politique
rappelez-vous étaient sidérés ne
comprenait pas le problème parce qu'il
faisait tout ça depuis des années chaque
année on nous avons nous découvrons des
pratiques des combines et c'est sans fin
je pense que la population les citoyens
ne réclame pas suffisamment cette
moralisation du citoyen à une doit
reprendre sa place et doit sanctionner
les élus indélicats et doit promouvoir
au contraire ceux qui proposent des
mesures visant à éviter les abus
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
a du mal personnellement j'ai grandi au
milieu de la guerre et sanctions
internationales et de l'injustice on
voit vraiment un singe
[Musique]
j'ai commencé à travailler avec les
enfants abandonnés en 2003 après
l'invasion de l'irak par les américains
ma mère m'a emmené dans une autre ville
où j'ai vécu avec ma tante
ma mère est restée à falloudja c'est là
qu'ils sont morts nous sommes donc eu
nombreux ils sont maintenant orphelins
comme nos maisons que l'on rejoint
daraîche et je n'avais pas envie de
rester avec eux si je l'avais fait je
serais devenu l'un d'entre eux
[Musique]
j'avais peur mais monsieur hicham a
commencé à changer ma vie j'aurais
peut-être rejoint un groupe terroriste
ou un gang s'il n'avait pas été là ne
peut pas espérer que les enfants qui ont
grandi sans droits vont respecter ceux
des autres allaient mener quoi
[Musique]
mme halimi netanyahu salue une journée
historique le plan de paix de donald
trump pour le moyen-orient a été
dévoilée donald trump qui évoque une
solution réaliste à deux états mais
rappelle considérer jérusalem comme la
capitale indivisible de l'état hébreu
washington annonce qu'elle va connaître
reconnaître à l'économie
victoire palestiniens occupés comme
faisant partie d'israël un plan de paix
de 180 pages contestée par les
palestiniens
hier on vit aujourd'hui à paris entre
forces de l'ordre des pompiers ces
derniers manifester de nouveau pour
exiger une revalorisation de leurs
conditions de travail notamment la prime
il est question de leur retraite un
mouvement de grève avait débuté en juin
à l'hôpital public toujours en crise
comme annoncé il y a deux semaines des
centaines de chefs de services
d'hôpitaux ont démissionné de leurs
fonctions administratives en cause de
l'inaction de l'état mais aussi un
manque de moyens depuis mi janvier plus
de 1300
avant d'annoncer leur mission au niveau
national
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci de nous rejoindre
en direct sur rt france c'est donc un
plan de paix de 180 pages qui a été
dévoilée par donald trump une chance
historique pour les palestiniens
d'obtenir un état indépendant selon lui
on fait le point avec notre reporter
thomas bonnet à tel aviv
on retiendra d'abord les images celle de
donald trump et de benyamin netanyahu
réunis au pupitre pour à cette annonce
cette annonce donc d'un plan de paix
wind des deux parties manque cruellement
c'est dire le déséquilibre affiché pour
cette annonce donc du deal du siècle
tels que donald trump m le présenter le
président américain et le premier
ministre israélien qui ont eu des mots
très amicaux la envers l'autre très
élogieux avec de nombreuses poignées de
mains des applaudissements et des
congratulations échanger l'un envers
l'autre
et puis donald trump a donc pris la
parole pour détailler ce fameux plan je
n'ai pas été élu pour faire de petites
choses a déclaré le locataire de la
maison blanche qui a expliqué qu'il
souhaitait trouver je cite une solution
réaliste à deux états on écoute le
président américain ma vision présence
une occasion gagnant gagnant pour les
deux parties une solution réaliste à
deux états qui résout le risque que
représente un état palestinien pour la
sécurité d'israël
aujourd'hui israël fait un grand pas
vers la paix et puis donald trump a donc
détaillé les différentes mesures de son
plan avec il faut bien le dire un
certain nombre de paradoxes paradoxe
d'abord lorsque donald trump explique
qui veut faire de la ville de jérusalem
la capitale indivisible de l'état
d'israël et dans le même temps il
propose aux palestiniens de faire de
l'est de jérusalem la capitale de l'état
palestinien il propose même d'y
installer une ambassade américaine
autre paradoxe lorsque donald trump
évoque la souveraineté d'israël sur les
territoires occupés et qu'il promet en
même temps de doubler les territoires
palestiniens le président américain qui
explique qu'il veut approuvé l'annexion
de la vallée du jourdain part à l'état
d'israël et en contrepartie de tout cela
il souhaite investir à hauteur de 50
milliards de dollars dans les
territoires palestiniens et cela pour
créées selon lui un million d'emplois
donald trump qui a à la suite de son
annonce postée une carte sur son compte
twitter une carte qui serait donc le
résultat de l'application de ce plan de
prêts promis par le président américain
à l'issue de son discours benyamin
nétanyahou a ensuite pris la parole il
s'est félicité évidemment des
propositions de donald trump expliquant
qu'il avait réussi à trouver je cite le
bon équilibre
il a également souligné le fait qu'il
s'agissait selon lui d' un jour
historique on les écoute deux stores etc
c'est un jour historique et il me
rappelle un autre
nous nous souvenons du 14 mai 1948 parce
que ce jour là le président truman est
devenu le premier leader mondial à
reconnaître l'état d'israël après que
notre premier ministre david ben gourion
a déclaré notre indépendance
ils ont ouvert la porte à un avenir
radieux
monsieur le président je pense qu'au
cours des prochaines décennies et
peut-être au cours des prochains siècles
nous nous souviendrons également du 28
janvier 2020 car ce jour là vous êtes
devenu le premier leader mondial à
reconnaître la souveraineté d'israël sur
des zones comme la judée samarie qui
sont vitales pour notre sécurité et qui
sont au coeur de notre patrimoine
reste à savoir maintenant si ce plan
sera applicable dans les faits il paraît
très peu probable aujourd'hui qu'il le
soit puisque les palestiniens semblent
le rejeter en bloc et ce malgré le fait
que donald trump a expliqué vouloir
trouver une solution où les deux parties
doivent être gagnante
ce n'est pas la vie des palestiniens
après l'annnonce de donald trump et
depuis la locution des présidents
américains israéliens les réactions
internationales se multiplient pour
téhéran le plan de donald trump est
vouée à l échec un plan mort-né pour
ankara londres évoque une proposition
sérieuse alors que moscou appelle ils
seraient les rip est destiné à négocier
directement et pour michel raimbault
essayiste et ancien diplomate on ne peut
pas parler
d'un accord je pense que finalement ce
n'est pas un à-côté ne peut pas être un
accord de paix puisque l'une des parties
concernées notamment les palestiniens et
les grandes victimes de cet accord n'ont
pas été non pas qui est temps que la
négociation d'accords été négocié
uniquement par l'habilité les états unis
et puis israël
donc ça ne peut pas être mais il est
vrai qu'on a renoncé à voir une solution
de problèmes politico constitue la cause
palestinienne et le conflit israélo
arabe
on n'en faire qu'une transaction
commerciale alors à coup de milliards de
dollars ils ne sont pas payés par
l'amérique d'ailleurs il est sans doute
par les émirats par la saudi toute autre
famille donc on arrive à cette
proposition lésiné je pense que ça très
peu de chances de réussir puisque
personne aucun palestinien n'a
finalement accepté cette solution avant
même temps que d'être les clauses qui
qu'on ne connaît pas la teneur exacte du
document j'ai bien entendu mais il ya vu
la belle cérémonie d'amour entre eux
monsieur natanyahou et monsieur paul
mais il n'y avait pas main quand absence
n'est pas le smic sont les dindons de la
farce en tout pas les grandes villes ne
vive colère dans les rues du
moyen-orient après l'annoncé du plan
américain c'était le cas notamment dans
les territoires palestiniens à gaza ou
encore un manant jordanie des
manifestants qui sont descendus dans les
rues pour témoigner de leur opposition à
ce plan porté par washington et
protestataires qui s'insurge contre les
déclarations de donald trump et benjamin
netanyahu nous sommes certains que notre
peuple palestinien ne resterait pas sans
réagir devant ces complots
donc toutes les options sont sur la
table l'occupation israélienne et
l'administration américaine porteront la
responsabilité de ce qu'ils ont fait
c'est notre droit de résister à
l'occupation
c'est notre droit de résister à cet
accord et c'est notre droit de résister
à quiconque essaie de détruire notre
existence et notre jérusalem de réfugiés
sont prisonniers non sanctuaire nous
avons le droit de tenir tête à ceux qui
nous dit très heureux que nous signons
pour perdre la palestine mais nous ne le
ferons pas personne en palestine ni en
jordanie n'acceptera de renoncer à ne
serait ce qu'un millimètre de palestine
ou de renoncer à jérusalem ou au droit
au retour ou de renoncer à nos
frontières et un autre pays à notre
terre notre pays à la palestine de la
mer jusqu'au jourdain avec jérusalem
comme capitale
si dieu le veut ce sera la capitale du
peuple palestinien est la capitale de
toute la nation arabe et musulmane
journée de manifestations pour les
pompiers qui annonce mettre fin ce soir
à leur mobilisation après les annonces
de christophe castaner ils ont notamment
obtenu une revalorisation salariale à
maintien de leur système de retraite et
une augmentation de leurs primes de feu
de 6%
le ministre de l'intérieur a salué la
décision des syndicats de mettre fin à
la grève et des annonces du ministre
après une manifestation donc marquée par
de nombreux aujourd'hui dans la capitale
plusieurs milliers de pompiers ont
manifesté pour dénoncer le manque de
moyens et exiger le maintien de leur
système de retraite
trois interpellations annoncé retour en
images sur les fortes tensions lors de
cette journée
m
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
je
sur les réseaux sociaux les violences de
cet après midi ont fait réagir de
nombreuses personnalités politiques
les pompiers dans la rue les forces de
l'ordre n'hésitent pas à leur taper
dessus
gaz lacrymogène à gogo ils ont osé faire
grève et ne pas respecter l'itinéraire
ils dénoncent le manque d'effectifs et
de reconnaissance et demandent des
garanties pour leur retraite guerre
fratricide
selon le ministre lunn aise la police
aurait porté à bout de bras la
république dans la répression des
manifestations retraite
la macro ni en est là la police matraque
les pompiers frapper ainsi ce qui sauve
nos vies est indigne le régime
autoritaire macro nist défigure la
république crs posez vos casques et
matraques rebellez vous vous ne pouvez
être fiers d'impliquer ses ordres
absurdes à nouveau des images
terrifiantes de pompiers en colère
matraquer les français ont eu macron et
le chaos
macron et le chaos ces images sont
désespérantes
emmanuel macron qui a réussi à jeter nos
policiers contre nos pompiers devraient
réfléchir à l'immense responsabilité qui
est la sienne dans la profonde des
unions de notre pays
les policiers tabassent les pompiers
institutions contre institutions la
macro nice et la division et le chaos
lorsqu'un pays voit descendre dans ses
rues pompiers hospitaliers enseignants
étudiants chercheurs avocats
l'orchestré de l'opéra de paris et tant
d'autres c'est bien que sa société
craque de toutes parts
emmanuel macron doit savoir on n'est pas
prêt de lâcher la sphère manifestation
violences en marge de ces mobilisations
nous avons reçu christophe crépin porte
parole de france police pour en parler
écouter
je sais qu'il y avait eu un blessé léger
du côté des pompiers
mais je vous dire que ma soeur ma parité
syndicale france police policiers en
colère nous sommes
avec les peaux les pompiers qui ont des
doléances qui nous sens pour nous
légitime à la serre du fait que les
violences où nous avons toujours dénoncé
aujourd'hui les instructions de la
préfecture de police sont très claires
il faut vraiment qu'il n'y ait vraiment
aux femmes de possibilité d'avoir deux
casses ou quoi que ce soit c'est la
raison pour laquelle cette manifestation
est temps qu'elle brille d'une manière
très serrée des dispositifs policiers
justement aujourd'hui comment quel est
le dispositif policier justement juger
des gendarmes mobiles gd des compagnies
républicaines de sécurité et aussi des
dispositifs de la préfecture de police
qui sont tout au long chemin vous des
deux chiffres comme ça parce que en fait
c'est évolutif en fait on avait des gens
qui sont tout le long de la
manifestation
là on va arriver sur la fin de cortège
sur le fait qu'ils veuillent puis
laiteries sur le périphérique
je pense que c'est inconcevable parce
que ils exposent eux mêmes leur vie et
ils s'exposent à des complications assez
conséquente
concernant leurs doléances pour nous
elles sont louables mais faut pas
oublier une chose pour vos
téléspectateurs c'est que en fait les
pompiers travaillent sous instruction du
ministère de l'intérieur comme la police
nous on n'est pas du tout opposée aux
pompiers au contraire on apprécie
beaucoup de travailler main dans la main
et là aujourd'hui la préfecture de
police ou donne des instructions qui
sont très clairs et qu'ils sont
justement pas de ne pas de ne pas
laisser à la porte ouverte à quelques
les actions que ce soit le collectif
inter hôpitaux a mis sa menace à
exécution aujourd'hui 27 chef de service
de l'hôpital robert debré ont
démissionné de leurs fonctions
administratives pour défendre le service
public hospitalier
hier une cinquantaine de médecins et de
chefs de service du chu de rennes avait
déjà fait de même le point avec
sébastien dufour et david luiz et louis
augmentation du budget et des salaires
voici leurs principales revendications
depuis dix mois les personnels soignant
s'inquiète de l'état de santé de
l'hôpital public
nouveau signe de cette montée de tension
les fermetures de lits et le manque de
personnel qui touche aujourd'hui tous
les services les démissions s'enchaînent
ce matin ce sont une vingtaine de chefs
de service de l'hôpital robert debré à
paris qui ont mis leur menace à
exécution
toutes les personnes qui participent aux
soins dans cet hôpital sont là pour
soutenir les chefs de service dans cet
acte symbolique et qu'ils sont en train
de faire parce qu'on n'est pas entendue
parce que on n'a pas de soutien et qu'on
est là a pour nous on est là pour
pouvoir continuer à soigner
c'est un geste inattendu ça a déjà été
pratiqué jusqu'à présent est ce que ça
sera suffisant
on l'espère c'est du moins
l'espoir d'être entendus au moins une
fois par nos instances
au niveau national plus de 1300 médecins
ont annoncé leur départ depuis
mi-janvier les démissionnaires ne vont
plus participer aux réunions qui ne sont
pas directement liées aux soins des
patients à la recherche et à
l'enseignement
c'est un geste inédit et bouleversant
pour nous pour exprimer à quel point le
défaut des couches de ce gouvernement
comme des précédents est devenu graves
dans le fonctionnement de tous les jours
syndicats et collectifs de soignants
appelle désormais à une nouvelle journée
de mobilisation le 14 février pour
exiger que le gouvernement ouvre de
véritables négociations
le 14 novembre dernier un médecin
hospitalier sur quatre et plus de 10% du
personnel paramédical avaient battu le
pavé
partout en france on ne tient pas compte
de la crise de l'hôpital selon stéphane
augé chef du service de réanimation
pédiatrique à l'hôpital robert debré
décisions difficiles
ça fait à peu près à moins que nous
étions avec nos équipes à en discuter
que nous avons prévenu que nous en avons
parlé avec notre direction nous avons
rencontré la ministre il ya quinze jours
lors de nos menaces et ça a été
compliqué d'arriver jusqu'à ce matin
l'état d'esprit des collègues était une
très très grande motivation nous étions
donc nous sommes donc 28 même ses 75 %
des chefs de service de l'hôpital à
avoir porté notre démission à notre
directeur
c'est une décision lourde longuement
réfléchi mais qui et qui effectivement
très compliqué c'est à l'administration
que nous devons faire passer le message
de faire remonter à nos tutelles et je
pense maintenant au premier ministre à
monsieur le président de la république
on ne peut plus avancer comme ça qu'il
faut mettre tout de suite sur la table
les quatre revendications principales du
cih et c'est cela notre objectif c'est
de rajouter à la grève de la facturation
dont nous avions déjà parlé sur cette
antenne ya quelques semaines ce geste
fort sur tout le territoire pour
qu'enfin on puisse débattre est avancé
pour l'hôpital public
au taureau prud'hommes pour les salariés
de goodyear ils contestent le motif
économique de leur licenciement en 2014
la première audience en 2018 n'ayant pas
permis de trancher
elle nouvelle s'est ouverte à 9h ce
matin mes galas mégacité amiens le point
avec katia technique
c'est le second procès aux prud'hommes
des anciens employés de goodyear
aujourd'hui il souhaite évidemment
porter une demande d'indemnisation mais
également que leur travail et leur
dévouement pour leur ancienne société
soit reconnue c'est bien sûr un procès
historique aujourd'hui puisque pas moins
de huit cent trente deux anciens
salariés poursuivent leur ancien
employeur goodyear devant les tribunaux
alors évidemment un tribunal était trop
petit pour les accueillir il a fallu
délocaliser le procès est ici à mégacité
cet art complexe de congrès à amiens et
dès 7h30 du matin plus de 600 personnes
sont venues assister à ce procès hors
norme un petit rappel des faits en 2014
l'usiné goodyear d'amiens nord a fermé
1134 emplois y ont été licenciés et l'
usine a fini par être rasées aujourd'hui
c'était l'émotion pour les anciens
salariés
je vous propose de les écouter on espère
vraiment que ce soit prouvé encore une
fois parce que c'est pas la première
fois que c'est un licenciement abusif et
on attend vraiment des réponses est con
que goodyear enfin reconnaissent que
c'est que ces licenciements abusifs tout
le monde malheureusement dans des
circonstances comme ça tout le monde se
revoient et ça c'est vraiment important
pour nous ça nous permet justement m'a
dit de prendre un peu des nouvelles de
types différents collègues
malheureusement il ya des collègues
qu'il n'y en ait un qui viendront pu
parce que voilà ils sont et sur des cds
mais on pense à eux et on se bat aussi
pour eux j'espère qu'on a tous les
goodyear c'est que reconnaissent déjà le
travail effectué on a réalisé dans cette
usine
parce qu'il fallait que courageux pour
travailler à goodyear surtout fallait
être courageux pour produire jusqu'à 24
mille peu de jours et je peux vous dire
qu'il ya pas beaucoup d'usinés en europe
à l'époque il était capable de faire ce
cette production et nous à goodyear
amiens nord on l'a réussi en touche et
des des produits nocifs
à l'époque on nous a pas dit que c'était
nocifs et je pense à tous ces gens là
qui sont tombés malades
pour certains qui est pour certains qui
en sont noirs et aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
de là où j'espère que il j'espère que
l'on va gagner pour eux l'avocat des
anciens de goodyear maître fiodor rilov
est un grand nom du barreau également un
habitué des combats contre les
multinationales il a expliqué ce matin
lors d'une plaidoirie fleuve de quatre
heures que la société l'année 2014 année
la fermeture avait un profit record 2,5
milliards de bénéfices et donc
l'argument économique pour licencier les
anciens salariés ne tenait pas je vous
propose de l'écouter
ainsi que d'écouter mickaël wamen qui
est le porte parole des anciens salariés
de goodyear de démonstration faite au
conseil des prud'hommes
d'abord les profits pharaonique réalisé
par goodyear au moment même où ils
licenciait les 1200 salariés de l'usiné
d'amiens nord sont non seulement une
situation scandaleuse mais surtout une
situation illégale on ne peut pas
licencier des milliers de personnes
lorsqu'on fait en même temps
simultanément des bénéfices aussi énorme
et je pense que ça c'est à la portée
de tout un chacun de comprendre qu'il
faut que le groupe qui décide ainsi de
fermer son usine pour faire encore
davantage de profits soient lourdement
sanctionnés
son exemple en quelque sorte dissuasif
va démontrer avec des preuves pas
uniquement avec des paroles mais des
preuves concrètes que cette
multinationale qui a fermé cette usine
est en réalité a fait tout et n'importe
quoi violé tous les règles de droit
élémentaires et donc on va voir ce que
va dire l'apathie adverse après midi
mais pendant près de quatre heures
fiodor a fait une démonstration qui est
limpide voilà il ya même pas l'ombre
d'un doute sur les faits qui sont avérés
c'est à dire que goode eurent à fermer
l'usiné alors qu'il était en santé
économique
excellent d'ailleurs c'était sa
meilleure année une année record
aussi bien en termes de résultat net
après impôt qu en termes de dividendes
donc une fois encore on est dans une
situation où la variable d'ajustement
pour faire pour en verser plus de
dividendes aux actionnaires
c'est la masse salariale et donc c'est
les séries qui ont emprunté après la
pause c'est l'avocat de goodyear qui a
repris la parole et qui a expliqué que
l' usine d'amiens nord n'avait pas assez
de rentabilité à l'époque et que toutes
les offres que ce soit en terme de
restructuration ou les offres de
propositions de départs ont été toutes
refusées par qui par la cgt et les
salariés et que donc il s'agissait d'
obstruction cela a fait beaucoup réagir
dans la salle en tout cas aujourd'hui à
amiens il y a un espoir de enfin tourner
la page goodyear après toutes ces années
pour d'anciens salariés qui entre temps
sont devenus une véritable famille
et 4k européen de contamination entre
humains en allemagne aujourd'hui le
coronavirus continue de s'étendre en
europe les explications avec florian
lambert le couronna virus continue de se
propager en europe
un premier cas de contamination entre
humains sur le sol européen a été
confirmé en allemagne
il l'aurait été après avoir rencontré
une personne venue de chine dans le
cadre de son travail
contrairement aux autres patients
signalés en europe qui ont quant à eux
étaient contaminés lors d'un séjour sur
le territoire chinois
le patient en question va bien cependant
il est toujours isolée dans un hôpital
de munich où il est placé sous
surveillance médicale
l' enquête sur la personne contaminée et
conduite avec la plus grande célérité
notamment dans son environnement
familial et professionnel qui ont déjà
été informés le risque de contamination
du patient reste très élevé
particulièrement dans son entourage
familial et dans les entreprises des
alentours qui ont évidemment été informé
en italie les passagers à bord d'un vol
en provenance de hong kong ou été
contrôlés hier par des professionnels de
santé en france les trois personnes
hospitalisées à paris et bordeaux
restent les seuls cas confirmés dans
l'hexagone
le gouvernement français a annoncé le
rapatriement de ses ressortissants de la
ville chinoise de wuhan
l'avion devrait être normalement à bourg
ain jeudi soir donc ça veut dire qu'il
part mercredi avec le décalage horaire
il arrivera jeudi après-midi à roanne
nous sommes en constitution de l'équipe
médicale qui va accompagner cet avion
l'objectif c'est de pouvoir identifier
sur place il ya des personnes malades
pour qu'elle fasse l'objet d'une prise
en charge particulière et d'un transport
particulier et que nous ne mélangeons
pas
des personnes malades et des personnes
sans symptômes
les autorités japonaises ont également
annoncé ce mardi la présence au japon
d'un cas de contamination chez un homme
qui ne s'est pas rendu en chine mais il
en véhicules et des touristes en
provenance de wuhan berceau de la
maladie le nombre de victimes du
coronavirus s'est aggravé à 106 morts
4500 cas sont confirmés dans toute la
chine selon un dernier bilan des
autorités nationales ignore le gène a
reconnu par l'onu annoncé aujourd'hui
avoir abattu un drone appartenant aux
forces du maréchal haftar une frappe qui
a eu lieu dans un climat tendu les deux
parties dénonçant les violations du
cessez-le-feu en vigueur depuis le 12
janvier
nous avons eu accès à la ligne de
démarcation où se font face les deux
camps rivaux des images exclusif avec
théo combat à bout queen à 300 km de la
capitale tripoli le drapeau du
gouvernement d'union nationale flotte
sur la ville
un calme relatif semble régner sur la
cité côtière
mais à quelques kilomètres de là
l'état des routes témoigne de la
violence de récents combats c'est là que
le front s'est stabilisé entre les ville
clé de misrata et de syrte
les troupes de khalifa haftar et celle
du geanah se font face depuis l'entrée
en vigueur d'un cessez le feu le 12
janvier grâce à la médiation d'ankara et
de moscou une très fragilisé par de
nombreuses escarmouches entre les deux
camps ce que confirme soldats pro
tripoli qui relate une attaque des
forces de l'est
ils ont répliqué et certains véhicules
et engins ont été détruits
puis ils se sont déployés dans la région
un territoire meurtri par la violence
des combats qui se sont déroulés depuis
l'offensive du maréchal haftar contre
tripoli
en avril dernier une zone sinistrée où
subsiste le dernier hôpital de la région
c'est le seul hôpital qui soigne les
gens de cette région
c'est plus un dispensaire pour les cas
d'urgence la plupart des personnes
traitées viennent des environs comme
bush qui a beaucoup écrit malgré les
mesures annoncées lors de la conférence
de berlin le 19 janvier dernier la
mission des nations unies en libye a
regretté ce dimanche la poursuite des
violations flagrantes de l'embargo sur
les exportations d'armes vers le pays
le conflit libyen se poursuit depuis
plus de neuf ans et c'est la fin de
cette édition on se retrouve demain
matin à 7 heures du matin heure
française pour un nouveau journal et un
point complet sur les pieds
[Musique]
l'actrice de 2008 arrive et à ce moment
là on s'aperçoit que les choses ont été
mal faites
on n'avait aucunement prévu des
scénarios d'euclide de défaut de
paiement tant qu'on maintient la grèce
avec les mêmes conditions qui ont
provoqué cette crise
vous aurez le même système il serait
plus cohérent qu'elle reprenne son
existence en main monnaie comprise mais
je reprendre sa monnaie ne résout pas
tous les toutous mes problèmes
bien sûr qu'il faut changer les hommes
qui dirigent parce que sinon vous ne
résoudrait rien en sortant de l'euro on
veut en fait forcé la marche du
transformation d'un pays donc
effectivement peut-être que certains
grecs ont envie de voir cette marche de
transformation du fonio et sans aucun
doute une grande partie n'ont pas envie
de cette transformation son entrée dans
l'euro est en grande partie responsable
de ce qui lui arrive
il semble qu'il existe une architecture
naturel reposant sur le pli quel
avantage la nature aux rétais la
pratique et l'origami et comment
peut-elle produire des schémas de pliage
aussi complexe
[Musique]